Da-da-da-da!
Hello, everybody.
Welcome and
howdy-do-dy.
Before we start... I have some fruit I wanna eat.
I hope that's okay.
Small squishy.
Not squishy.
What kind of fruit?
Oh, no.
A variety.
Oh, well, actually, okay, I have a variety of fruit.
I made a fruit salad yesterday.
And then... I went to a bakery today and I got, for the first time, I got this fruit... What do you call this?
Fruit pastry.
Delight.
And I'm trying it for the first time ever.
And you guys are gonna hear my reaction.
But right now, I'm just eating some fruit.
Because I just... I don't know.
I just want some fruit.
How are you guys doing today?
How was your weekend?
Tell me everything.
What you been up to?
Blueberry.
Good.
Mother's Day was nice.
You clean.
Good.
Catching up on a vod of what?
What are you watching?
Chores and rest.
Good.
Sea of thieves.
Oblivion.
Doing homework.
Doing laundry.
Leftover pizza.
Did you have a good maid day?
I did.
Happy Mother's Day.
Why are you guys saying Happy Mother's Day to me?
Is it because I'm a cat mom?
My cats are really annoying today.
15 minute break.
For my fourth day working in the Pokemon Mines at PAX East.
It's crazy out here.
Maddie sent me a picture.
My friend Maddie.
Oh, that's Raspberry.
She sent me a picture of Minto, Minto plush, Chibi Minto plush taped to the information booth at PAX East.
She sent me, she sent me this photo.
Finally, it's my turn to request a birthday song.
Wanchop, I'm so sorry.
I'm not doing birthday songs right now.
But I can say happy, happy birthday, Wanchop.
Happy birthday.
Oh, yeah, hold on.
Let me get it.
I'm eating banana.
Where is it?
She said, I get to meet all your crazy fans.
And then I said, they're also your crazy fans.
I think if they're meeting you too, they're also one of your fans.
This is the photo she sent me.
She said, yeah, she sent me.
Oh, she also, she also got this.
She also sent me this picture.
Sorry, Maddie.
I didn't ask her for permission to post these, but hold on.
She also sent me this one.
Oh.
Hello.
This.
And she said, you're so tall.
I know.
I'm like towering over.
I'm towering over, Snake.
Future Beyond.
It was my birthday last Thursday, but I haven't been able to catch a stream due to travels.
Thanks for your encouragement.
I finally started getting out of my shell to try new things I might enjoy.
P.S.
I met a Nobel Prize laureate over the weekend.
Whoa.
Happy birthday, Future Beyond.
Thank you so much for the Haka Super.
Thank you.
Ow.
Sorry.
I hit my mic.
Hang on.
I told Maddie, have fun and enjoy your bubble tea.
It looks really yummy.
I wish I could have had a sip.
But this is kind of terrifying.
This photo is kind of...
It's kind of crazy.
She looks so snug.
And also like...
So...
I don't know how to say it.
I don't know.
So...
Like she's being contained.
Pineapple.
It's where she belongs.
It has aura.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
For sure, for sure.
Thank you for streaming on my birthday, Minto.
Oh, Eggie, Eggie, Eggie, Eggie.
Eggie Vaughn, happy birthday.
Are you...
Am I what?
My mod never ever says anything.
And sometimes cryptic stuff.
It's a face that says I'd do it again.
Yeah.
Got my plush towering over Lego Tokyo.
Nice.
Just like Godzilla would do.
I...
So, we're back in the oblivion.
We're back in the oblivion.
And...
What happened last time?
Oh!
Last time we started, I thought I was gonna assassinate people.
And I did my best.
But I was not powerful enough.
Every time I would assassinate a guy, he would be like, Help!
Help!
And then the guard would come immediately.
And I'd be like, Uh-oh.
So...
That's not good.
I have to get more powerful so I can assassinate him in one fell swoop.
And then, I was like, Okay, well, for now, we'll continue the main quest.
Since I, uh...
need to get stronger.
So I went back to Kvatch, also to get my horse.
And I, uh...
You'll never best Tutius Sextius.
We haven't even tried him.
We haven't even tried.
I tried David.
Davidie.
And so...
We...
Went back to Kvatch, and it was overrun by...
The Daedra.
The portal to Oblivion opened.
And I...
At first, didn't go through it.
And then I went through it.
And I went through it.
And our pal died by floating in the air.
We don't know how that happened to him.
He was flying!
And then he fell...
And died.
To Cusis...
Noi, noi.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
And then...
We saved...
The future...
The...
The son...
Of the old...
Emperor.
The old king died...
And we saved his son, who was the priest at Kvac.
And then we were gonna take him to... To Winry Priory.
And we went there, and then... Aeronarn... was like... Gop, gop, gop, gop, gop, gop, gop, gop.
He... He... They suddenly started attacking that place.
May or may not still be in that.
We don't know.
Legendary moment.
And there was definitely someone behind him.
And he was like, I think they're behind me.
He was definitely... He was right behind him.
I've never heard that sound bug.
It's my favorite thing ever.
As Todd Howard said before, it just... It just works.
Yes.
Gop, gop, gop, gop, gop, gop, gop, gop, gop.
And... So now... We have to transport...
We have to transport...
The son of the emperor to a place where he won't be...
He will be safe.
But before that, I'm gonna try this pastry.
It has fruit in it.
I wonder what the cream is like inside, though.
Oh!
It's all over my fingers.
It's messy.
Oh!
I can't get it out.
Hold on.
Oh, my goodness.
There's cream all over my fingers.
Oh!
Oh, wow!
This is really much thicker than I thought.
Oh!
Wow!
This is so good.
Hold on.
Let me try though.
With the orange.
Oh!
Wow!
It's so yummy!
I'm gonna go put this back in the fridge and go wash my hands...
I'll be right back.
I'm just licking up the cream.
I can't even eat the pastry part.
I think I need a proper plate.
Okay.
Let me go get it.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
That was not... Oh, I put my headphones on backwards.
I don't want to be Barry.
That was not a stream time treat.
I apologize.
Okay.
All right.
Let me take a sip of my tea.
And let's get into the game, baby.
Yeah.
Finally, 20 minutes in.
A little too messy.
Also, stop being freaks in the chat.
Stop being freaks.
I tell you.
I tell you now.
Stop being freaks.
Thanks for the recap.
Couldn't catch last stream or VOD.
So awesome to know.
Oh, yeah.
Of course.
All right.
I believe it's this.
Yes, yes, yes.
It's this one.
We're only level five.
Been a while.
Hope you've been good.
I'm good.
Thank you.
Hey, what's your bedtime reading material tonight, Minto?
I haven't listened to anything recently.
Finally.
Um...
Nope.
How's your glass house, Minto?
We load the game.
Wait.
Oh, it's... What did I call it earlier?
It's... Weynon Priory.
I think I called it... Winery or something.
Welcome back to Weynon Priory.
Oh!
That's one of the guys we just killed.
Dang!
He's got riches!
Oh, my goodness!
And then also say hello.
Oh.
E-Tina.
Don't look at him.
Yep.
That's E-Tina.
Wait.
What do you got?
They've all...
They used to not carry gold.
But now they've all got gold.
Let's go.
What time is it?
Oh, it's almost 3am.
This game is so bright.
It's like hard to tell that it's like...
Oh, it's 3am.
Boy, 3am.
Hmm.
This place looks so run down for it actually being like, you know...
Used?
Looting bodies at 3am?
Oh, yeah, I am.
Nothing.
Absolutely nothing.
Our money now.
Could be worse a game where you can't see squat.
So true.
But it makes me think that the sun is coming up.
Like any second now.
I'm like, oh.
Look how beautiful it is.
Yes, let me know.
What was that?
Let me know if I need to do anything with sound.
And or...
Graphics.
This guy was hungry.
Okay.
I think that was all of them.
Sound good so far?
Okay, cool.
So...
We know where we must go.
We must go to...
From here...
To here.
Can we fast...
Trev...
Yeah, we can!
But it's like...
So lame to do that.
I've never been here before.
So I don't wanna do that.
Do the scenic route.
Oops, sorry.
I'm hitting my mic.
Hold on, I'm adjusting stuff real quick.
Yeah, I kinda wanna take the scenic route.
I kinda wanna walk there.
Is that okay?
My immersion is shattered if you fast travel.
So true!
A single gold.
Okay.
Let's do it.
And they're up here.
Oh!
You guys are much closer than before.
Hello, Joffrey.
As a blade, my place is at Martin's side.
He's got the blade.
Joffrey's got his katana.
And we're going to Cloud Ruler Temple.
Which totally sounds like a place...
That is...
Like a Zelda temple, no?
We are Boo Joffrey.
With the amulet taken by the enemy, we must get Martin to safety at Cloud Ruler Temple.
It does, right?
Cloud Ruler Temple was built long ago by the founders of the Blades.
Back in the days of Raymond Cyrodiil.
It is high in the mountains near Bruma.
High in the mountains.
Our ancient fortress, sanctuary, refuge of last resort.
Martin will be as safe there as anywhere.
Cool.
One of the youngest blades ever to serve in the Emperor's personal guard.
I am glad to hear that he survived, but I fear he will take the Emperor's death particularly hard.
Fast traveling to somewhere you've never been before feels wrong.
I agree.
Especially because I want to see everything in this game.
Who are the Blades?
Boris.
I am the Grand Master of the Blades.
We serve the Emperor and the Septim Bloodline.
Talos is our patron.
You wonder to find me here?
Discretion is our watchword.
Only a few of us have the honor to serve publicly in the Imperial Guard.
Emperor Bodyguard Army.
Dragonfire.
The coronation of each new emperor is sealed when he uses the Amulet of Kings to light the Dragonfires in the Temple of the One.
The Dragonfires of Akatosh remain lit until the death of the Emperor.
His successor then lights them anew upon ascending to the throne.
With Emperor Uriel dead and no successor crowned, the Temple of the One will be dark for the first time in centuries.
Oh my god.
Elder Council.
The Elder Council rules in the Emperor's absence by ancient tradition.
Old.
Chancellor Akato heads the Elder Council and is the closest thing the Empire has to a leader right now.
But the Blades answer only to the Emperor, of course.
We are not an arm of the government.
What if...
They don't want a new Emperor?
Or...
What if that Chancellor guy is like...
I'm sending the dark people to...
To kill...
So that I'll become...
The Emperor.
The Daedra Prince of Destruction.
Oh, that's right!
An inveterate foe of all mortal races.
He was involved with Jaegar Tharn's plot against the Empire years ago.
Maybe.
It doesn't surprise me to find his hand in the current calamity.
Mm-hmm.
We should get moving.
I won't rest easy until Martin is safe at Cloud Ruler Temple.
You okay, Martin?
Let's continue on to Cloud Ruler Temple.
I haven't had a good night's sleep since Kavach was attacked.
How long were you waiting there?
The sooner we reach Cloud Ruler Temple, the better.
Alright.
Lead on!
Are you coming with me, Joffrey?
Let's go.
Everybody?
Autobots?
Wait.
Are you coming too, or...?
I think Brother Piner is staying here.
Everyone else?
Roll out!
I love walking for the silly diversions.
They will happen.
Most likely.
Alright, team.
Where are you going?
What?
Oh, they have their own plans, I guess.
My horse is over here!
They're kicking up so much dirt.
Oh wait, is he...
He's getting his own horse.
Oh my god, they get their own horses!
What if I didn't have a horse?
I can talk to the horse.
Let's continue on to Cloud Ruler Temple.
I haven't had a good night's sleep since Kvach was attacked.
Dang, I thought they were just gonna be...
Follow me, yeah.
I thought they were just gonna be...
...running after me.
While I rode the horse.
Good thing I didn't steal those horses.
No!
What if I did take those horses?
Alrighty.
Team!
We're going here because...
The reason why I was like, let's go to this place first before we...
...try to assassinate...
...the guys at Skingrad.
I haven't even been to Anvil.
Oh my gosh, there's so much.
Um...
...was because...
We were kind of like, in the middle of this...
This...
I didn't want to just leave him here.
I wanted to...
I wanted to deliver him to the temple and then we could continue with any other...
...quest that we felt like we wanted to do.
Like meeting Gray Fox and...
Yeah!
Oh, wait.
Okay.
What's Pilgrimage?
I don't care.
Oh, this is the one in Anvil.
The one that was at the attack chapel.
We have so many...
So many quests.
Okay.
Um...
I'm guessing it's this one.
Onwards!
He's that ninja.
Yeah.
Um...
Oh...
Yeah.
Wait!
Is that it up there?
Wait, you guys see that?
You got...
It's like hidden amongst the trees.
Wait.
See that tower?
What is that?
Oh wait.
Sorry.
My chat...chat was...the one right next to chat.
What is that?
It looks kind of beat up though.
Hold on.
Go to...the right.
DLC home.
I...couldn't find any DLC to buy.
On...steam, you guys.
I looked because I was curious.
People were like, DLC.
I couldn't find anything.
It's part of the game.
Oh.
That's not...that's not DLC.
I don't think.
I don't think that counts.
Oh, it was DLC in 2006.
Oh, originally.
Wait.
Whose house?
Oh, no.
Paint horse.
Uh...oh.
Uh-oh.
Um...
Team?
Oh, gosh.
You scared me.
Team?
All you have to do is follow the road.
What is...what is happening?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, uh-oh.
Oh, oh.
You're a good guy.
You're...you're just...you're a good guy.
Yes.
Oh, my gosh.
Scared me.
I thought he was a bandit.
I say good guy.
I don't know.
Well...Ignore the dog.
Oh, shoot.
Dang it.
The dog will not ignore us.
Ooh!
Ah!
Oh, gosh.
Scared the hell out of me.
Oh, my God.
No.
Help!
Your horse is escaping you!
Why does the dog have money on it?
Get back on your horse.
Why did you get off your horse?
Oh, my God.
I hate...
I hate escort missions.
Hello, sir?
Any room?
Oh.
You...I've seen your kind before.
What?
You've got blood on your hands.
Keep your blade sheathed, you murdering bastard.
Or I'll put you down myself.
I served my time!
Oh, damn!
Emperors have been assassinated before, but...
This time...
I don't know.
It's different.
Can't you feel it?
A shadow is falling across all of Tamriel.
He won't even look at me.
Farewell, citizen.
He hates me.
It's fine.
I hate him, too.
Oh, he killed that dog for me.
You...I've seen your kind before.
He called me a murdering bastard!
Is he wrong?
And I'd do it again.
He's taking the shortcut.
Every time.
Don't run into me.
Don't do it.
Etina does not pass the vibe check.
What do you mean?
Of course he does!
I'm not a thief.
I borrowed it.
He just misunderstood my intentions.
And then tried to kill me.
And I killed him out of self-defense.
Oh, hold on.
Wait a second.
This other road...
Where am...
Oh, right here.
It's not even on the map.
Where could it go?
Okay, detour!
A little detour!
I'm just curious.
Oh, shoot.
That's a dog, isn't it?
I'm ignoring him.
He'll leave us alone eventually.
Whoa!
Miranda!
Who is she?
Oh my god, it's an imp!
Oh my god.
Oh, horse, run!
Horse, run!
Oh, shoot.
I'm adding
my horse on fire!
Are you okay, horse?
He's so traumatized.
Gosh, dang!
What a trooper.
My poor horse.
Where'd the other guy go?
Well, there he is.
Nasty.
Um, hold on, team.
This looks to be...
Is this a... a dungeon?
Miranda.
I'm just gonna look inside real quick.
Why were they harassing...
Oh.
What's this little sneak peek?
They're not coming in.
I just wanted a peek.
I just wanted a little sneak peek.
I can't take those.
Just want a little sneak peek.
They really hit the horse for some reason.
Suspicious.
What was that horse up to before you got him?
Oh my god!
The horse...
That's why they couldn't come in!
The horse couldn't fit through the door!
It's alright, team.
We discovered a new spot.
We will be back.
Horses can report your crimes to the guards.
Including their own theft?
Huh?
I pray to Todd you can find a phone.
What do you mean?
Wait, how can the horse...
Do that?
We must not get distracted, team.
I...
As much as I want to...
Plunder and pillage...
And dungeon and crawl.
We must deliver this man to the temple.
Horse whisperer.
I don't hear them.
God dang it!
Why are they so slow?
Uh-oh.
Wait, what was that?
Oh, there he is.
There's one of them.
I think I see the other.
Just very slowly...
There you go.
Alright, team.
Onwards.
What?
I don't...
Why do they refuse to take the road?
At least if I'm fastest...
Oh, wait.
Gladimist Cave.
See, this is another road that's not even on the map.
The Red Ring Road.
Cave.
Is this a cave?
This looks like a cave.
Oh, yeah.
This is the cave.
Oh, I think we found the cave.
What the heck is this place?
Don't go in there.
Uh-oh.
I'm trapped.
Turn around.
Beep, beep.
Oh!
No, no, no, no.
God, no.
Please, horse.
Oh, it's the Imperial City.
Oh, okay.
Come on, team.
We're all accounted for.
Why?
Why is it so easy to lose you?
Okay.
They just don't keep up at all.
All right.
Onwards.
Okay.
All right.
We're all good.
I'm too quick.
I've...
I put all my stuff into speed.
Hmm.
I don't hear footsteps behind me.
Should I really try and buy a house?
Cause like...
Oh, there's another cave we're about to come up on.
What is...
What's a house good for?
In this economy?
What is...
Oh, that's Miranda.
That's the cave.
Okay.
Wow.
It's so peaceful.
It's almost like...
We never got attacked.
I'm backing up.
Oh, there they are.
Okay, you're fine.
You can roleplay.
That's exciting.
Oh, golly.
This looks dangerous.
Is this...
Is this sturdy?
You are the boss.
Oh my gosh.
I thought you were...
A bandit for a second.
Hey, hold on.
Let me talk to you.
Oh.
You have my ear, citizen.
I am a citizen.
Oh, hold on.
Let me talk to you.
Good morning.
That horse's ass.
Don't look at it like that.
Any rumors around here, soldier?
If you've got to travel by the Nine Divines...
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Carry on.
I will.
And so will my team.
Oh, gosh.
We lost the old man.
Oh, no.
He's over there.
Okay, we're fine.
Ooh, it's getting chilly.
It's getting a little cold.
Around here.
What?
Oh, wait.
Another...
Another fountain thing.
Oh, this is where the road goes.
I see a dog.
I'm gonna get his ass first.
I'm gonna get him first.
Don't worry.
Yeah.
Get his...
Get that dog.
Alright.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
No other dog?
I got that dog.
Are you gonna kill every dog we come across?
They attack me!
What do you...
What do you want from me?
There come...
It's self-defense, literally!
Wait.
Is this the road?
Wait, what's...
What is this way?
What's down here?
I must explore.
We're filling out our map.
It's not murder.
It's self-defense.
I promise.
It's the truth.
It's the doggone truth.
And that dog is gone.
Just like that guard.
That was also...
Defense.
Oh, this thing doesn't work.
Back it up.
Pre-emptive self-defense.
Wait, where's...
Oh, hello.
What a silly guy.
It was self-offense.
Am I on the road?
I'm just like in the...
Oh my gosh, I'm a true pioneer.
I'm off the beaten path.
I'm off the map.
They can never find me.
I'm where...
I'm...
I don't pay property taxes.
What's attacking me?
Okay, maybe that's just normal music.
Look at that view.
Oh, I know.
Where are we going anyway?
Atina running from taxes.
Absolutely.
Running from the law.
Running from taxes.
What's that over there?
Mysterious.
Wait, where are we?
What?
How did I get back on the path?
Oh my God.
Here I thought...
Wait.
Wait, but what's down...
So...
If I go down there, there's nothing.
Where are the guys at?
Hello?
Martin's so far behind.
Where do you think he'll come from?
Wait, is that his horse up there?
Wait.
No.
That's a...
What is that right there?
Is that a tree?
No, that's a horse.
Why is there a horse up there?
Who is that?
Is that him?
Why aren't you moving?
Wait.
Hello?
He's moonwalking down the room.
Stop doing that.
The hope of the world.
Oh my goodness gracious.
Wait, it's this way.
He was struggling so much and...
The other guy had no problems.
We're in the Jer...
Jer...
The Jerbal Mountains.
Wow.
Oh my gosh.
You know what?
Let's just keep going.
They'll...
They'll catch up.
Oh!
Oh, please.
Oh shoot.
No!
Dang it!
If only I hadn't missed that first shot.
Where'd my arrow go?
Eaten.
It was a...
It was a sacrifice.
Oh!
You guys made it!
It was a...
Sacrifice for the rock.
Oh, it's foggy up here.
Oh!
Another...
Another dog.
Get off!
Oh!
He sat down.
Maybe there was a good pup.
I don't think so.
It says wolf.
Okay.
Onwards!
Damaged one times.
Awesome.
There's a glowy stone up there.
Hold on.
I'm checking the map again.
Okay.
We'll go to the left.
Wolf can be...
Good pups.
Can they?
Me?
Or...
Are they all...
Murderers?
And...
I think that all of them want to eat my horse.
And for that I cannot forgive.
Imperial City.
Bruma.
Just stay on the pathway!
Why is it so difficult?
Whoa!
Okay.
I think we're here.
Wait.
Do we have to go through the city?
Yes.
Whose house is this?
Oh.
Stables.
Oh, look at that.
What a lovely horse you've got.
Would be a shame if it was needed for some...
Imperial business.
Hello, guard.
Oh.
He's so small.
What?
Frost Crag Spire has been uninhabited for so long.
They say it was as wondrous as the Arcane University itself.
What?
Okay, bye.
What the?
Whose horse is this?
Oh.
This is the final boss.
We must use the real royal guard.
This is who we have to get through.
To get into the city.
Oh.
Uh...
Wait, my horse can't...
Wait.
Hold on.
Do I have to ride around the city?
So I can use my horse?
Just go around the city.
Yes!
Oh my goodness.
Okay, back it up, everybody.
Back it up, team.
Back it up.
This way.
Oh, I wanted to...
I was really excited about seeing the city.
That horse was like...
Only one horse is allowed in the premises.
Aww.
Going on the way back.
Yeah, yeah, I will.
Is that it up there?
That doesn't look very...
Like it...
I don't...
Is that inhabited?
The controls are like a semi-truck when backing up.
I mean, look at that.
Horses.
We're back in the gerbil mountains.
Okay.
Uh...
Oh my...
What the?
Who are you?
Oh!
They just killed that guy.
Was that guy a bandit?
Well, they did me a...
Solid.
Oh.
The Imperial Legion is at your disposal, citizen.
What seems to be the problem?
Uh...
Nothing, actually.
Emperors have been assassinated before, but...
Okay.
They all say the same thing.
Farewell, citizen.
They have the Imperial Guard hive mind.
Where are the guys?
Oh, there you are.
Okay.
That guy was just trying to hunt some deer and they shot him down.
That's pretty crazy.
Easy.
So we need to go...
This way?
I suppose?
Nature reserve.
Ooh.
I think it's this way.
I think?
Hold on.
I'm double checking the map.
Yes?
Yes.
No.
Uh...
Wait.
Like, up...
Here?
Hold on.
Let's try around here.
To the east?
East?
Oh, I think we follow this path.
Yeah!
I found it.
I thought you meant weest.
How the months fly.
Thank you, Nexy!
Yeah.
How they fly...
Oh, here we go, here we go, here we go.
Thank you so much for the...
Thank you!
Cloud Ruler Temple!
Alright.
They'll get here soon.
They'll be here shortly.
I'm gonna look around a little bit.
Don't fall.
Oh, I...
Oh, gosh.
Etina, I know you can fly in the movie, but don't do it.
See, that's what I was seeing before.
Oh, I see an imp down there.
You think I could snipe that guy?
Oh, let's go in, guys.
Get off your horse.
Yeah, we're here.
Yep, we're here.
Come on in.
Oh, I need a key.
Uh...
You have a key?
Oh.
Yep, yep.
May Talos guide you.
God recommended your Choco Minto music video.
Will we see you sing it anytime soon?
Well...
I'll put myself in your hands.
It's a...
Grandmaster, is this...
Hold on.
Yes, Cyrus.
This is the emperor's son, Martin Septim.
My lord.
Welcome to Cloud Ruler Temple.
We have not had the honor of an emperor's visit in many years.
Wow.
Ah, well, thank you.
The honor is mine.
Come.
Your blades are waiting to greet you.
Oh my god.
No...
No way.
And everything!
Oh my gosh.
Konnichiwa.
Inspired.
The emperor and his sons were slain on our watch.
The empire is in chaos.
But there is yet hope.
Here is Martin Septim, true son of Uriel Septim.
Oh yeah, genius.
Oh god, they scared me.
Hail!
You will be safe here until you can take up your throne.
In Japan.
Joffrey.
Oh.
All of you.
I know you all expect me to be emperor.
I'll do my best.
Best.
But this is all new to me.
I'll do my best.
I'm not used to giving speeches, but...
I wanted you to know that I appreciate your welcome here.
I hope I prove myself worthy of your loyalty in the coming days.
That's it.
Thank you.
Best.
You couldn't do a second take.
We'd all best get back to our duties, eh, captain?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, you scared me.
The blade saluting me and hailing me as Martin Septim.
Yeah, that's you.
I don't mean to sound ungrateful.
I know I would be dead by now if it weren't for you.
Thank you.
No one expects me to suddenly know what to do, how to behave.
They want an emperor to tell them what to do.
And I haven't the faintest idea.
You need a little, you know, you need a little, a little ghost to whisper in your ear.
We need to get the amulet back.
Of course.
The amulet of kings.
So we, I, can take it to the temple of the one and light the dragon fires.
And stop the oblivion invasion.
Best way to end an inspirational speech.
And you will be the emperor.
The emperor.
That's an idea that will take some getting used to.
In any case, we need the amulet first.
Maybe Joffrey will know where to start.
Yeah.
All practitioners of Daedric magic are familiar with the almost impenetrable barrier between our world and oblivion.
What the emperor told you implies that the amulet is the key to the preservation of that barrier.
What I saw at Kavarch.
Everything I know about Daedric magic says that such stable portals are impossible.
Yet those gates to oblivion existed.
The old rules no longer apply.
Kavarch is only the beginning of what Mehrunes Dagon will do.
Mehrunes Dagon.
If the amulet is truly the key to restoring the barriers between our world and oblivion, you must waste no time in recovering it.
Supposed to be a mix of Japan and Rome with some jungles mixed in?
But somehow it ended up as Lord of the Rings.
I haven't always been a priest.
In my youth, I followed a different path.
What's that?
I know more than I want to about the seductive power of Daedric magic.
Let's just leave it at that.
Are you trying to seduce me, Brother Martin?
Something has changed to make these stable portals to oblivion possible.
They're getting help.
Joppa believes that the death of the emperor and the darkening of the dragon fires is the key.
Oh.
They're getting help.
Don't worry about me, my friend.
Good afternoon, ma'am.
I know I'm in good hands.
Ma'am.
Hi.
Hello.
Wait.
Where are you going?
Good evening, mom.
Good evening.
Where are you going?
Let's follow him.
I want to see his room.
Ma'am.
Whoa!
Wow, you got in here so fast.
You're not actually reading this.
Don't...
Wow!
They gave you the biggest slab of me I've ever seen in my entire afterlife.
There's so many books here.
Brief history of the empire volume.
Legend of Cradley house.
What's that?
I like legends.
Oh my gosh.
Phil, thank you so much for the...
Thank you.
Is that me?
Oh, sorry.
Did I hit my mic again?
Let me rawl.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, it's a...
Play.
Imperial Man 24th Thief.
The famous...
Haunted...
Cradley house?
Oh, oh.
Requiring a stage with a second story where most of the action takes place.
The stage is dark.
There's a creaking noise.
Footsteps on the stairs.
The sound of a man breathing.
But still, we see nothing.
Then a voice calls from above.
Hello.
Is someone down there?
Should I wake Papal?
No.
Maybe I was imagining.
This is 25 pages.
Oh my gosh.
The night they were murdered.
Is this an autobiography?
They'll just assume it's the ghosts.
The curtain falls.
Ten commandments.
Nine divines.
They say that all the time.
Who's mysterious Akavir.
Akavir means Dragon Land.
Tamriel means Dawn's Beauty.
Atmora means Elderwood.
Only the Red Guards know what Yokuda ever meant.
Big minky love.
Thank you.
Akavir is the kingdom of the beasts.
No men or mer live in Akavir.
Though men once did.
Vampires?
Snow hell?
Demons?
Uh.
These men, however, were eaten long ago by the vampiric serpent folk of...
Seis.
Tasty.
Real Berenziah is basically your smut audio books.
Wait, what?
Which one?
Where?
Wait, this one?
No.
Biography of Berenziah?
No, no, no.
No.
Biography of Berenziah?
That one?
It's censored?
No kidding.
Oh.
Oh my god!
You scared me.
Oh.
Good afternoon, ma'am.
Good afternoon.
They're chomping.
Good evening, ma'am.
Good evening.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Oh, that...
Oh my god.
She will love the lusty Argo...
Argo...
Argonian maid.
Yeah, I know about that one.
Only because, uh...
Um...
Mogu...
Told me about it.
So this one?
37 pages.
And that's vault...
42 pages!
6...
I just spat out my...
I was in such shock.
I spat out my...
My...
Cough drop.
Can I get...
A TLDR?
What are you reading?
I brought him here though.
I feel like I should be able to look into anything that I want.
How are you?
The real Baron Zaya on the table.
Oh!
But it's been censored though.
Is that what people said?
Thank you so much for the redirect!
Thank you!
Oh!
But this is volume 4.
It's okay.
Everything I have ever loved, I have lost.
Baron Zaya thought, despondently.
Looking at the mountain knights behind and ahead.
Her tired woman near her in a carriage.
Yet I have gained a measure of wealth and power.
And the promise of more to come.
Dearly have I bought it.
Now I do understand better.
T-Tiber Septon's love of it.
If he had often paid such prices.
For surely worth is measured by the price we pay.
Do I go thank you so much for the fight?
Good to thank you!
By her wish she rode on a shiny roan mare.
Clad as a warrior in resplendent chain mail of dark elven make.
When does it get...
The kiss.
Marry me, Baron Zaya!
I don't even know who this is.
Oh my gosh.
She seemed to have picked up her thoughts on marriage, children, wives.
Oh my god.
Symmachus.
There was work and there was pleasure.
And what more could one ask of life?
Wait, is this the last book?
Of, of, uh, of, uh, oh.
That peasant obeys whoever holds power.
Always has, always will.
We shall hold the power, milady love.
His lips were sweetest wine.
His touch.
Both fire and ice.
Now, she said.
Take me now!
I'm ready!
Her body seemed to hum every nerve and muscle taut.
Not yet.
Not here.
Not like this.
Oh my goodness.
The wall dissolved.
Uh-oh.
What's the...
Does it end on a cliffhanger?
Gosh, they're really chomping away.
Alright, let's explore this place.
Just a little bit.
Then I'll go talk to...
Joffrey.
You can meet her?
I don't...
Ma'am?
Caroline?
What can I do for you, ma'am?
There's no place more secure in all of Cyrodiil.
I just wish...
Yeah.
I wish we could have gotten our Lord Uriel here.
The Emperor's death was a harsh lesson for all of us.
We failed in our duty to the Dragonborn.
Joffrey.
It must not happen again.
So true, lady.
May Talos guide you.
Thank you.
Joffrey.
Hold on.
Oh, look at them!
Oh!
You missed.
Oh, you got him.
Nice.
Wait, can I be in there?
Oh, sorry.
Ma'am?
Get out of the way, ma'am.
Woo!
They're training hard.
Look at them go!
Ma'am?
Wait, there's blood on the ground here.
Oh, my gosh.
I guess they, uh...
You know...
By observing these blades of practice, you've picked up a couple of new moves.
Your blade and block skills have both been raised by two points.
Wow!
It pays...
To be observant.
Wow!
That's crazy.
All you need to understand is...
Wait, what?
Is the...
This world is a dream, and when the dreamer wakes up, it is gone.
What?
Ha?
Hail.
Nah, it's sucking.
Oh.
What was that?
Something just fell...
Oh.
Oh, no.
I think it's snow.
It's not hail at all.
I want to go see what that is.
Which one's my horse?
Wait, where's my horse?
Uh-oh.
Still outside, probably.
We will check it out.
But first...
I want to check out a little bit in here.
By the way, the book censored is the real Barren Zaya Volume 2.
Aw, man.
Why'd they censor it?
What's he reading?
I haven't time to talk right now, I'm afraid.
But I'm sure one of the other blades can help.
Try speaking with Belisarius or Caroline.
Oh.
Okay, Baragon.
You're not even...
He's angrily looking at me.
While he turned the page.
You're not even reading it.
Baragon.
Sure.
Well, then he won't notice if I look in here.
I'm just looking.
I don't have time right now.
I'm too busy reading...
The real Barren Zaya Volume 2.
Hail.
What's it?
Oh.
Whoa.
I'm just looking.
How cute.
I wish I had a shirt like that.
Hail.
Don't mind me.
Oh.
That looks like...
What I throw in my...
Dryer.
It's fine.
I brought the new emperor here.
I should be rewarded.
I brought him here.
Oh.
They should be kissing my feet.
The old emperor.
Volume...
Seven?
Anyway.
Hail.
Yep.
Me too.
Oh.
Poor sucker.
Who is this?
Who has to sleep in here?
Whoa.
Gosh.
I wish I had a katana like that.
It looks so nice.
Ma'am.
You can get a free one from Joffrey?
How do I get out of this?
Wait.
Where am I?
Oh.
I went to their...
I went to their room.
Wait.
Oh.
Whoa.
What was that?
Oh.
I didn't do that.
That fell all on its own.
Let's go talk to Joffrey.
We'll get ours legally.
Oh.
Are you still so busy, Baragon?
Damn.
He's chugging that.
Slow down, buddy.
Slow down.
He needs to savor the flavor.
Oh my god.
Baragon has a problem.
It's me.
No clock.
Hello, Joffrey.
I have a question.
You have proven yourself a loyal servant of the Empire.
As worthy as any of the Blades to stand by Martin's side during this crisis.
Thank you.
As the Grand Master of the Blades, I would be honored to accept you into our order.
Will you join us?
Oh.
What?
Yeah.
What are my duties?
The Blades are sworn to the service of the Emperor as the mortal representative of the Dragon Blood of the Divine Talos.
Okay, but there's this guy named Gray Fox.
I want to join him, too.
Will you join the anime club?
You can do both?
Thank you.
I will join the Blades.
It is my honor to welcome you into our ranks as a knight sister of the Blades.
I'll join everything.
I got a katana!
Keep your heart true, and your eyes open.
It really...
Good evening, ma'am.
I'm one of...
Oh.
Good evening.
I'm one of you now.
Wow!
Does this count as, like, a slight...
Like, well...
I guess it doesn't count as, like, a...
You know, uh...
Yeah, it's a long sword.
Yeah.
Sad.
It's okay, though.
It's okay.
Let's put our...
When did I...
Oh, yeah.
That's right.
I got this other one.
The enchanted one.
I've got my fist up.
Wait, so now can I take...
Welcome aboard, ma'am.
It will be an honor to serve with you.
Can I take everything in here now?
I can wear their armor.
I could be...
Oh, I really can!
Hail!
Achilles!
I'm still trying to adjust to everything that has happened.
I know.
You gonna use that, or...
I actually...
Oh, sorry.
I didn't mean to take the plate.
My finger slipped.
I just gotta, you know, a little...
I just...
Oh, here you go.
You can have it back, too.
Hello, my friend.
Where did it come from?
The plate is...
Good minerals, maybe.
Probably.
I feel like the armor will be too heavy for me, though, no?
Hail!
Please forgive me, but I'm afraid I haven't got time to talk right now.
Oh, gosh.
Baragon.
Baragon, we really gotta talk to you about...
That guy's not okay.
Okay!
I want to...
Well, there's my horse.
Quests.
Finding the thieves' guild.
So we must...
Go to...
The garden of...
Derloth.
Let's do it.
And then, I also wanna kill that guy at the inn.
I wanna do all the freaky stuff.
Where is it, though?
Where we gotta go?
Oh, here?
I have to go to the...
Wait.
Is this...
It?
No, this is a Cloud Ruler Temple.
What the heck?
Hmm.
I don't know.
Should we do this one first?
Or should we do...
Let's see, actually, which one is closer.
Knife in the dark.
Oh.
It's way further.
So we'll...
We'll join the...
Thieves' guild on our way to joining...
On our way to...
Knifing that guy.
There we go.
Oh.
Okay.
The Imperial City, I feel, wasn't so far away.
And then...
Oh my gosh.
Who knows how many quests are in here?
Someone described...
The...
Oh.
The Elder Scroll games as big plays.
And that all NPCs are actors playing a bit for the player.
Even the cosmic lore hints this.
Oh.
That's neat.
Quap,
quap, quap.
Yeah, what part of that was in the script?
Quap, quap, quap, quap,
quap.
I want to go in, but...
I want to go in...
But my horse, I'd have to come back...
You know what?
Let's do this.
We'll ride to the other side.
And then I can go in and explore for a little bit.
And then we can...
Just leave where we came and...
Pick up our horse.
The quap, quap was part of the script.
Oh.
It must be like a secret meaning.
We just are so...
We are so uncultured.
We don't understand it.
Yeah, it feels very Truman Show.
No.
That kind of description.
That's freaky.
What are they going to start advertising?
Hello, everybody.
I'm listening.
Nah.
Greetings.
What exactly do you require of me?
What's going on with you?
They say that slavery has been abolished in Morrowind.
House Dress and Lalu have renounced the slave trade and freed the beast folk from servitude.
It seems that these are turbulent times in the land of the Dunmer.
Take care.
What?
That's what I'm asking you.
There was slavery?
Also...
How are you?
Hi.
Good evening.
That guy was walking around with short sleeves.
How is he not so cold?
Uh-oh.
It's so night, though.
Like, it's starting to get pretty dark.
They won't want to talk to us or let us shop or...
Here, let's just go into this person's house.
A true north man.
That's true.
Oh.
Hello.
Can't you see that I'm upset?
Oh.
You are?
I can't help myself.
I'm just a sucker for well-heeled men.
That Ola, for example, at the Tap and Tack.
He's dreamy.
And successful, too.
Ola...
Anyone looking for work should consider the Fighters Guild.
I hear they're always looking for recruits.
Okay.
Why is she upset?
Good riddance.
Why are you mad?
What happened to you?
Why is she so mad?
Why are you upset?
Damn, I really missed out on that plot line, huh?
Steal her cup.
Let's go to the Tap and Tack.
It's you.
Hi.
What?
Do I have a reputation here already?
Ola, Ola, Ola.
Let's meet this guy.
He's dreamy, apparently.
Okay.
There's three people here.
Which one do you think is Ola?
They're all looking at me.
They're not even eating.
Or conversing.
Or anything.
Middle back.
That guy over there.
Right?
Nope.
This is Surutan.
Oh my gosh, how cute.
Surutan!
Okay.
So it's not him.
This guy is so dreamy.
This has got to be him.
Today's your lucky day.
Oh my god, it is!
Don't let's hear it.
What?
Hello!
Hello.
This is him.
He looks like Fabio.
What can I do for you today?
You know what?
Now that you mentioned the play...
Every time I click on a character...
It's like a spotlight comes down from the heavens.
And like...
And shines on their face.
The Countess is Heartland Nibinean.
And so are most guildsmen and chapelmen.
But most others are as Nordish as you'll find.
Alga sure can tell a good story.
I'm not normally a big fan of Bard's tales, but she's got some good ones.
Do you think he's into me?
I've got a room and a cheap one at that.
You're looking for one?
No.
All right.
The...
Oh, we can...
We can...
Barter with him.
So?
Good journey to you.
So he'll buy our stuff.
That's good.
Greetings to you.
Oh my gosh.
What's upstairs?
Oh, but I can open this.
Oh, I can't be lockpicked.
Dang.
Oh my gosh.
Doesn't even have a TV.
You don't even...
Guide to Bruma.
Cute.
What else you got?
Okay.
No toilet.
Yeah.
Hello.
How much would...
I take it, you want.
Nope.
No Wi-Fi.
Oh.
What's she up to?
She looks suspicious.
I take it you want something.
Well, what is it?
Well, you're...
What can I do for you?
You're running away.
What are you doing?
Hey.
You're the one they call the Hero of Kvatch, aren't you?
The one that closed the Oblivion Gate and saved the city?
Oh, quick save so you can get better social.
Oh.
The guy looks like the prince from Shrek 2.
Oh my gosh, he does.
Take care.
I'm the hero of Kvatch.
I'm the hero.
Hammer and axe.
This city is way less dizzying than Skingrad.
I think I just don't like Skingrad.
Nova Roma.
Oh, that must be like a...
Magic.
Hey, why are you putting hero in quotes?
I saved that town.
Yes, I did.
They're so rude to me.
You don't know you're talking...
How can I help you?
You don't know that you're talking to a hero.
I'm that mean.
Hello?
One more coin and I can get a pair of shoes.
Did you ever hear about the ghost of Lord Vlindril?
They say he haunts the road to Coral.
Not that I've ever seen him myself, mind you.
What?
Where?
Blessings of a new...
What?
The road to Coral.
Where the hell is Coral?
Here.
This road?
Which road?
Which where?
A ghost?
I must...
I want...
We went this whole way, but it was daytime.
The road to Coral.
This...
Maybe this one.
A ghost?
Toss a coin to Armito.
She saved the Emperor's son and joined the blades.
Yeah!
I'm no hero.
Never was.
Never will be.
Going around and telling people I'm not a hero sounds like something not a hero would say.
Wait.
Can you tell me that again?
Wake up.
One more.
Yeah, I'll give you a coin.
Give me a second.
Did you ever hear about the ghost of Lord Vlindril?
The road to Coral.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Thanks for telling me about the ghost.
Who has things of Akatosh upon you?
I want to go see the ghost.
Oh gosh.
Can I...
Oop.
Nice.
Let's get out of this...
What's this...
Ghost bottom right.
Viguro thank you so much for the coin.
Thank you.
Let's...
Actually...
Have I been to Coral?
Yes, of course.
No.
Actually, I don't think I have.
I don't think I actually explored Coral.
Yeah, only outside.
But what we can do...
Is we can fast travel to...
Wayne and Priory.
We would just be going the same way that we went.
And then...
Let's explore...
I don't know.
I don't think this is a quest or anything, but...
Oh, thanks, horse.
Alright, perfect.
This way.
So...
We'll just go around...
What time is it?
Oh, that's the map.
It's 3 a.m.
Okay.
This is like the perfect time...
For a ghost to come out.
Let's see if there's a ghost around here.
Wait, where the hell am I?
I always press that on accident.
Wait, this way.
No.
Like around here.
Crumbling mine.
I don't see no crumbling mine, but...
Okay.
In the original, their voice would change with pay.
Really?
Why are they depriving us?
I can't believe they redubbed the whole game.
Oh, that's crazy.
Ghost lore question.
Are maith ghosts the same species as pirate ghosts?
Oh, maybe here.
Can you change class at will?
Or is made ghosts like a regional species thing?
Wait, I think that's a bandit.
That's not a ghost.
Uh-oh.
No, my fist!
Um, I could change if I felt like it.
Like, why would I change?
He's about to be the ghost.
Oh, my God.
What just happened to him?
Oh, shoot!
You've buffed yourself for no reason.
Oh, my gosh.
Horse, you scared me.
What, do you want his mace?
Do you want his mace?
Alright.
We're looking around for a ghost, guys.
Any ghost?
Watch this not be a real thing.
Watch this not be a thing at all.
My athletics have increased.
Now, there are lots of rumors around here, huh?
I just want to see it before it becomes...
Daytime.
My eyes are peeled.
I'm...
There are dark everywhere.
I'm looking all over.
For this ghost.
Maybe not this road.
He can be hard to spy if your timing is wrong.
Took me a few nights to see him.
No kidding!
Wait, what's this up here?
Oh.
Just a rock.
What?
Oh.
You cannot wait when there are enemies nearby.
What do you mean by that?
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Huh?
Of enemies nearby?
Where?
Huh?
Red arrow?
No, no.
Not that.
What?
Um...
Huh?
She doesn't see them.
What am I seeing?
What am I supposed to be seeing?
Is it a little crab again?
I just want to know what time it is.
I think we missed the ghost.
Aw, man.
In the trees?
There's still enemies!
I don't...
I'm so confused.
I just want to know what time it is.
Oh, there's a dog over there, I think.
Is that a dog?
Dog...
Or rock?
It's a dog.
Three times damage.
Hmm...
Well, if we can explore the city and then wait until nighttime again...
And come back...
I wonder, though...
I wonder...
What time would be best, though?
Hmm...
Wait...
Now see it'll let me check now.
6 am...
Maybe the...
Maybe it was the wolf.
6 am.
Yeah.
Into...
Coral!
Let me in.
I just want to see...
I just want to see the ghost.
That's so fascinating.
Oh...
I thought it was...
You know those, like, medieval things where you...
Well, okay...
First I thought...
It was...
Uh...
Yeah, well...
A guillotine.
Yeah, yeah.
First I thought it was a guillotine.
And then I thought it was...
The gallows.
A gallow.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Tiding citizen.
Oh, hello.
One second.
I'm going to try something real quick, you guys.
I kind of want to have some, like, mood lighting with this...
Game.
Let's try it.
Hopefully it...
Doesn't make me lag so much.
Let's try it, though.
I feel like it'll help.
It'll match the vibe.
Cause when I was, like, all lit up...
Some...
Say...
My name?
Oh.
Greetings.
Maybe.
Tidings citizen.
Tidings.
Good morning.
Good mor...
Whoa.
What is going on here?
Wow, you guys didn't take care of your stat...
Or your fountain at all.
Oh.
He's got no shirt on.
Why don't you lose the shirt?
It's a pretty statue.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, it's so pretty.
The mountains behind.
I saw the other day...
I don't know.
It probably showed up in your guys' feed, too.
Um...
The cosplay group of the...
Of the...
Um...
The group that were...
They were cosplaying the...
The statue versions of...
Freerun...
Characters.
So rude!
It was so pretty.
I'm a high-time titty.
You want something, I guess.
Or you wouldn't be messing up my air.
I'm just...
I'm just saying hi.
Yeah, I used to be fighters guild here in Coral.
But I've done some incarceration for trespassing and theft.
Couple of times.
You know, they kick you out of the guild if you get caught doing some incarceration.
How many?
I forget.
But I did a lot.
Oh, I wanna be your friend.
Say what you're going to say.
I wanna be your friend!
Not to say someone say my name, but autocorrect after me.
It's okay.
Someone...
Someone did save me.
What?
Sons.
They're going to fight off the creatures at our farm, but I fear for their safety.
Oh no!
Wait, this quest?
Wait, wait, why are you guys saying, oh no?
Creatures?
For the last few days, we've suffered attacks from these creatures at our farm, not far from Coral.
They're coming from some place in the Great Forest.
I don't know where, but Rallis may know more by now.
My boys will take up the fight, even if the guards won't!
It doesn't matter if it's outside the town walls, it still affects us all!
I like how...
They expect me to go with them, but I...
All the guys get so, like...
I fear in my old age, I'm not the warrior I once was.
They get so heated so quickly.
Would you...
Would you go in my place?
I don't know you!
Um, okay.
Somehow?
I knew you'd do the right thing.
I'm supposed to meet them at Wayne and Priory.
You'd best get whatever supplies you need now, so you can get there in time.
I...
I need a drink to calm my nerves.
Please, excuse me.
Have you seen my sons?
My sons!
Hello!
An honor to serve you.
I'm Imfrid, owner and publican of the Grey Mare at your service.
Oh.
A room?
Or food?
Whatever you wish.
Ignore the UNO reverse card in my hand.
It's your birthday tomorrow!
Happy early birthday, resting glitch face!
Happy early birthday!
You...
You've been working hard, and you deserve some rest.
Take it easy.
Take it easy for your birthday!
What the heck is a hack dirt?
Yes.
A small village south of Coral.
Used to be a prosperous mining town, but it has been nearly deserted for years.
Thank you, Minto.
Of course!
Be seeing ya!
Oh, sorry.
Let me take that out.
Average.
I think I could take it.
Hector.
You've been there before.
I was gonna say, I think, the name...
Actually, after they mentioned it, it sounded familiar.
What time is it?
Oh...
Hasn't even been...
One hour.
A coin for an old beggar?
Do you know...
You're a mooch!
I'm saving up enough for some medicine.
Do you...
What do you know about Gray Fox?
He's a fairy tale.
The Imperial Watch pretends there is a thief king named the Gray Fox.
We're gonna find a guy named Leech, I swear.
I swear we're gonna find a guy named Leech.
I'm thinking of heading over to Renoir's to buy some books.
There's quite a selection.
I thought you were saving up for medicine.
Nermis.
Here, you had me feeling bad for you.
I was like, oh, the guy just needs some medicine.
You're off to get books?!
Books?!
I spit on you.
Patooey!
Don't talk to me.
Wow, this city is so stinking cute.
Might be my favorite so far.
I like the mountains in the background.
Oh, I thought that said Alberic's little...
Alberic...
Alberic's little basement.
I was like, oh, he's got a little tiny basement.
Who's here?
Valis' house.
It's my birthday on July 22nd.
That's...what?
It's so far from now.
Celebratory...
Cop, cop, cop, cop, cop, cop.
Malintis.
How are you doing?
Just telling me we keep an eye on things here in Coral for certain interested parties.
Yeah, you can have a cop, cop, cop, cop, cop, cop, cop for any time.
Honestly.
Goodbye.
What you got in here?
Oh, my God!
Hello?
I'm Glistel.
What do you need?
You were hiding in the shadows.
You scared me.
My housemate, Malintis Anchris, and I are well known in certain circles here.
But you don't travel in those circles, do you?
What are you saying?
Your housemate's train?
Knowledge is power.
Wait, what?
Oh.
She can't help me train any higher with sneaking?
No!
Aw, man.
I got money!
I'm too sneaky already.
Followers...
We are the fingers of the fox.
The children of the shadows.
More commonly, we are known as the thieves' guild.
So...
Are the circles that they are in the thieves, maybe?
But...
There are but three rules for followers of the gray fox.
First, never steal from another member of the guild.
Second, never kill anyone on the job.
This is not the Dark Brotherhood!
Animals and monsters can be slain if necessary.
Third, don't steal from the poor.
The peasants and beggars are under the personal protection of the gray fox.
Particularly in the Imperial City waterfront.
Breaking any of these three rules means expulsion from the thieves' guild.
If you commit murder, you must pay the blood price to rejoin the guild.
Blood price is for each person slain.
You can pay any of the guild...
Doyen.
The Doyen are the hands and eyes of the guild master.
You take your order...
Why?
They're so strict!
I thought we were gonna be like...
This sounds more like Robin Hood.
Hmm...
Sorry, I'm new here.
Did I just see E.T.
on my screen?
Actually, you saw...
The Chist Not Handy Stables now offers to protect your horse.
Oh, my bad.
Wait, you saw...
You saw E.T.
in a...
It's definitely not E.T.
in a wig.
But also welcome!
Yeah, this is E.T.
in a...
Doyen are the hands and eyes of the guild master.
You take your orders from them.
You get your favors from them.
They can pay off the Imperial judges to remove your crimes!
For a small fee, of course.
I'm in the guild.
It shouldn't cost me anything.
Our guild master is the Gray Fox.
We don't talk about him in public.
However, we make sure that most folks think he is just a myth.
Sometimes if someone's dialogue is still white, they might have more to tell you if they like you more.
Oh, I see!
So that's why.
Because it was white.
With the beggar guy.
Okay, okay.
With the mooch.
The leech.
We're thieves.
Not mason or scribes.
Masons or scribes.
Each member steals at his own discretion.
The guild neither helps nor hinders with a burglary.
However, you will find that you can only sell stolen property to one of our guild fences.
Other merchants won't take hot merchandise.
Ooh, hot.
It's hot.
You won't be considered for promotion in the thieves guild unless you have sold enough stolen property to the fences.
The higher in the guild you rise, the more stolen property you need to have fenced.
If you should be called to help the Gray Fox in some special way, remember that the best source of information is the beggars.
Oh!
Their eyes and ears seem to be everywhere.
However, be prepared to spend a little coin.
They won't tell you anything for free.
At least, not anything.
True.
The guild takes care of its own.
The Doyen can remove the bounty from any guild member.
However, it takes money to bribe the guards.
The guild member must pay the Doyen half of his total fines to get rid of them.
Farewell.
So, yeah.
That guy can help me.
Interesting.
Honestly, I only want to join it because of Gray Fox.
Otherwise, I don't want to be a thief with morals.
Who are you?
I'm only asking for a single coin.
I'm only asking for enough to feed me kids.
Feed me kids.
Have a coin.
Now, tell me more.
No, no, no.
That's not what I want to hear.
I'm bribing him.
No, no, no, no.
Here, I'll make him like me.
Oh, see?
He already likes me.
Okay, here.
Hold on.
Okay.
What nonsense?
I doubt it.
Oh, that's...
You win this one.
Um...
I doubt it.
Oh, shoot.
What nonsense?
That's enough.
I like that.
A lot.
Okay, that wasn't so bad.
What?
That's it?
I can't...
Oh my gosh, he's expensive?
24 gold for plus 11.
That's craziness.
That's so crazy.
Okay.
Excellent.
I accept.
Of course you do.
I'm with you completely.
Yeah.
Are you looking for him?
I want to rid the city of him.
Yes, I want to work with him.
I think I trust you enough to tell you this secret.
Okay, yeah, tell me the secret.
To learn more about the Gray Fox, go to the Garden of Daryloth at midnight.
Oh.
Look in the waterfront district of the Imperial City.
I can say no more.
I already knew that.
I got the letter.
Blessings of Mystara upon ye.
Well...
That's fine.
We didn't know.
You...
Oh.
Wait.
It's not illegal.
It just said that...
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
Hold on.
I got this.
Oh my goodness.
I don't got this.
I'm so bad at the game now.
There we go.
I'm really good at lick pock...
Lick pocking.
I mean...
Block picking.
Talk to people with your weapon out.
Do the Riz minigame.
Then lower your weapon for plus 10 bonus.
Woo!
When the beggar says blessings...
Of Mystara as a reference to the classic...
Dungeons and Dragons.
Oh.
Takesho, thanks for the...
To give the...
Groom and...
Welcome to...
Bubbleship.
I'm so embarrassed.
Anybody home?
Oh, you're asleep.
Wake up.
Hello.
No, no, no.
Wake up.
I'm talking to you.
I meant to say lock...
What can I do for you?
Lock picking.
It's good to know we've got such a strong fighters guild presence here in town.
I'm sorry.
I'm new in town and don't know anyone.
Oh, you're new.
That's cute.
Good night.
Is all of your stuff in here for free?
Or...
Is it got no...
Is it got no gold or...
Nothing?
Just some linens?
Okay.
Empty urn.
Oh.
Nah, I don't feel like you're doing it.
There's probably nothing down there.
Ooh, no reverse card.
Good work.
Lickpucker.
No.
Why does my brain do this to me?
Why won't they let me in the watchtower?
Oh.
This place looks like where a ghost would be at.
Perhaps.
A very spooky graveyard.
I'm surprised there's no like dev names on here.
You know what I mean?
Like on the gravestones.
I think this is where I saw...
Oh.
What's going on here?
How'd you do that without even pulling on it?
Oh.
He got into stance.
Ready stance?
Ready and...
Oh, there he goes!
Not...
Oh.
Not very nice.
Can you train me?
How are you?
Honda Todd is the name.
Honda Todd!
I'm a hunter and mountain man.
Can you train me?
Not a nice place to visit.
Those that remember still tell stories about the bad old days.
The bad old days.
About 30 years back.
There was some trouble out there.
Bad trouble.
Legion had to be called in.
People killed.
Why are we licking the king of Pocky?
No!
Wait, you'll tell me more.
Everybody's talking about the hero of Kvatch.
They say she actually went into an oblivion gate and destroyed it.
That's me!
That's me.
I did die.
We'll see.
Wait.
Okay.
Hold on.
I'll have my weapon out.
I talk.
Yes.
Persuade.
Oh, wait.
It went down 10.
I don't think it's a 10 bonus.
I think it's a 10...
It already puts your...
It gives you 10 debuffs.
So...
10 bonus?
It does...
It then takes...
It takes you down by then.
Then you raise them up and you get plus 10.
Yeah, but I can also just start with the plus 10 here.
It goes back up so it's easier.
Is it?
What?
Oh, it's because of the cap.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Okay, okay, okay.
No, no, no.
Don't leave.
What can I do for you?
I'm trying to raise you.
The deer here are skittish.
Need to get them quick or they'll lead you a merry chase.
Poison on your arrows can help.
And it won't hurt the meat.
Oh.
Wait, wait, wait.
Hold on.
Wait, maybe he can train me.
There's much I can show you.
He can train me.
Wait.
Wait, this is awesome.
Hold on.
Let's persuade him first.
This better be good.
Okay.
Oh, please.
Oh, shoot.
Sure, that's cute.
Don't talk such rot.
I did not do so good with that one.
Amazing.
But that's okay.
All right.
Not now.
Not later.
Not ever.
Oh, damn.
Such adventure.
That's just talk.
Not bad.
Not bad at all.
Nice.
All right.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
This one's not great.
Sure.
That's cute.
What nonsense.
Oh, gosh.
Such adventure.
You can't scare me.
Oh, no.
That one was so bad.
Oh, that one was so bad.
Is that so?
No.
Not bad.
Not bad at all.
Uh, shoot.
Shoot.
Don't waste your...
My life is drab and wretched by comparison.
Negative phrase.
No.
Don't talk such rot.
Gracious.
Oh, please.
That's pretty good.
My speech craft skill has increased.
Let's go.
Oh.
Not now.
This is the...
Not later.
Not ever.
Oh, no.
Um.
That's pretty good.
Wait.
Uh.
That's amazing.
That's just talk.
No.
Oh, I messed it up.
That's just talk.
Sure.
That's cute.
Wait.
Uh.
It's okay.
Okay.
Now.
Actually.
Actually...
My life is drab.
And wretched by comparison.
Be seeing you.
Okay, now if I put my...
Weapon away...
Wait, wait, wait.
Come here, come here.
Tell me about Hector's...
Some say the Legion burned the town to the ground.
But it's still there for those that go looking for trouble.
Still folks living up there.
But no one you'd like to meet open.
That's right!
It was that super saucy town, no!
Okay, let's also train with this guy.
Wait, oh my gosh.
Is training worth it?
I feel like it is, though.
This guy has his athletics.
We even leveled up.
I mean, they're so good at Rizzing.
Yeah, yeah, it's free leveled up.
Well, free.
Oh!
Training is faster, but more expensive.
Not athletics.
I'm faster!
Can you get me?
Wait, can I take this?
Oh, I can!
My arrow's now.
Try again.
Yoink.
I'm Lumgro Barath.
The cheerful one.
My brother Kurz is not so cheerful.
I'm the cheerful one.
Block.
Oh, wow.
Interesting.
That's kind of fun.
Dogs are an orc's best friend.
Good protection.
Good companion.
Good eats.
The Briants have dogs.
Lots of them.
She's taking their dogs and eating them?
Hey, you're the one they call the Hero of Kvatch, aren't you?
Yeah, that's me.
The one that closed the Oblivion Gate and saved the city.
The well in Hector has low enough roof that you can power trend acrobatics there by spam jumping.
No kidding?
Also helps restoration through recovery fatigue.
Oh, damn.
Goodbye.
Okay.
Did I... I think I came in through here.
So...
Let's hear it.
Oh, no.
Sorry.
I accidentally ran into you.
Uh...
What we can do is I still want to talk to that ghost.
You know, I haven't forgotten.
Oh, the Mage's Guild.
I'm a part of that.
Fighter's Guild.
That person's house.
I still want to see the ghost.
Uh...
Hello?
Who's here?
Whoa!
I think I just walked in upon royalty.
Oh, my gosh.
They're so...
Wow, this place is so fancy.
Oh.
Hello.
Good work.
Good pay.
Want to join the guild?
Oh.
What's...
Oh, it's the Fighter's Guild.
No.
Farewell.
Wait!
I can...
I can level up.
Okay, I'll join the Fighter's Guild.
Actually, I'll just go sleep at the Mage's Guild.
Actually, I'll join the Fighter's Guild.
Work, good.
If you're looking to join up, you should...
Uh-oh.
Join the guild.
You won't regret it.
Ugh, too much work.
Ha ha ha ha.
Too much work.
I'll join it eventually.
We'll join everything.
But we gotta go level up.
How can I help you?
Been to Fire and Steel recently?
Rashida has some nice new swords in there.
Good.
And she's a friendly one, she is.
Rashida does a good job keeping fire and steel stocked with good weapons.
Maybe not the best in Tamriel, but good.
Take care.
How goes it?
Fire and steel, huh?
Anytime now.
Where's that?
What's going on?
We're here.
My acrobatics?
Let's go.
Ha ha ha.
Pretty elf.
Oh, hello.
Rashida?
Hello.
I'm Rashida, the smith.
And this is Fire and Steel.
Quality armor and weapons.
Repairs, too.
What can I do for you?
Nice.
Flint and steel.
Wait, what can you train here?
Let's see if we can't teach you a thing or two.
Armorer.
Can I interest you in some of my wares?
Way to find Iron Bow.
I have a steel bow.
Oh, it's about the same, huh?
It actually weighs less, though.
The steel bow is heavier.
But a fine Iron Bow.
Hmm.
Curious.
I double take every time I see ET.
Hmm.
White bow, actually.
Oh, my gosh.
White bow is about to break.
Oh, I just noticed.
That would be terrifying.
Yeah, time to risk her up.
I'm listening.
You're full of it.
She likes this.
Don't, please.
I'm sorry.
I'm not buying that one.
Not bad.
Not bad at all.
Okay, here we go.
Try again.
Uh.
No more.
You're frightening me.
I doubt you really mean that.
Yeah.
I get blah, blah, blah.
What a bore.
You're frightening me.
You're a big, fat liar.
What?
I accept.
I have no choice.
That's pretty good.
Oh, shoot.
Was that supposed to be a compliment?
Oh, no.
Uh.
Oh.
Was that supposed to be...
I accept.
I have no choice.
Good one.
Don't make me laugh.
Okay, we made it to 70.
We made it to 70.
Let's see.
Bartering.
May I interest you in some of my fine wares?
Yeah, let's haggle.
What if I bought...
What if I buy your items at 175% of their value?
Try and go...
Try to go...
Wait.
Convince people that it's a good idea to make...
No.
Don't do that.
Don't make...
Don't.
No.
She's an expert merchant.
She's gonna kick your wallet's butt.
Oh.
Oh, because this.
So am I.
I can't make that deal.
No.
Um.
How about at 41%?
Oh, wait.
Well, that's how much I would sell stuff at.
But it...
It still worked.
And we can sell the pearl.
Wait.
Where are the other things that I stole?
I stole those gems?
Wait.
It's all gone.
I stole those gems from...
From the temple.
Oh, I can't sell stolen stuff.
Oh, that's right.
Tell your friends about me.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Maybe I can repair...
I can repair almost anything.
For 20 gold?
Yeah.
That's pretty cheap.
Okay.
I think we're good.
You too.
Thanks.
Okay, nice.
I wanna use my repair hammers in case I'm out and about.
Like if I'm in a dungeon or something and need it.
Ooh.
What's going on?
Okay.
We're all good.
Let's go sleep at the...
Mage's Guild?
And we'll sleep until like...
What time does it get now?
It becomes nine.
I wonder.
What is it?
Hi there.
Do you ever spend time in the Oaken Krozier?
I've had many meals at the Oaken Krozier.
Everybody's talking.
It may not be the best in Osiradu.
But it suits me fine.
He acted like he didn't.
The bulls.
Everybody's talking.
Eight...
Oh, wait.
Eight p.m.
is night time.
Okay, okay.
Let's sleep.
Where's your bed?
Where's the bed for guild members?
Where's your bed for guild members?
Which is I.
I am a guild member.
Living quarters.
It's my birthday!
Do you think I could get a short song?
I missed my chance last year since I didn't know birthday songs were a deal back then.
And I decided to wait like a good wisp.
Aw, Fixie!
Yeah, give me a second.
Let me find a bed first.
Oh!
I found a bed.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Fixie the Reaper.
Ooh, happy birthday!
It's been a minute since I've done it.
Okay, sleep.
It's 12 PM, we'll wait for seven hours.
Four, three, two, one.
And we've ascended to level six.
Let's go.
All in on agility.
We'll do...
A little more strength.
Was it endurance that I was doing?
And endurance.
I think that's been kind of what I've...
what I've been...
allocating my stuff to.
Do you like...
Skooma?
What's that?
Somebody can't set an alarm like you're Nancy Drew.
We can always make our own.
When we wake up...
Okay, once I click confirm.
Okay.
What's in here?
Why is it...
on oblivion?
Oh.
Nice.
What's this...
Skooma nuts.
Wait, why is this door...
not allowed?
Where does it go to?
How curious.
How curious indeed.
How do I get out of here?
I'm lost.
Um...
I want to go back downstairs.
I'm lost.
Um...
The library?
Some books give you stats.
Yeah, I've been...
Oh.
I think...
Let me out of here.
I want to go see the ghost.
Oh my gosh.
This is such a cute little sitting area.
Wait.
You don't need to read them.
Just open them.
So if I read them...
Or if I open the book on oblivion.
I want to read it though too.
Assassination.
Emperor...
Whoa.
The emperor was assassinated.
Dang.
One day I'll be in one of these.
The origin of the mages killed.
Yeah.
I'm sure they got like...
Whoa.
They have the whole series of the real barons Aya.
This passage has been censored by...
Order of the temple.
He hissed angrily.
M'lady.
Stop calling me that.
Too spicy.
Wait.
Volume 5 is down there.
Why?
Look at all these books too.
Wait.
What time is it?
It's almost 8.
I need to figure out how to get out of here.
How do I leave this place?
Is it this door?
Where?
How did I come up here?
How do I get out of here?
Go to...
Bravo...
Wait.
Hold on.
Cut through the library.
Oh wait.
It's over here.
Get me out of here.
I don't think there was a...
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
I just didn't see this door.
Okay.
Wait.
Uh...
Hail.
Goodbye.
How goes it?
Nope.
Don't talk to me.
Come to Braville.
Censored Passage was in a previous sus game and involved a spiky cat man...
...member?
Wait.
Is this the right one?
Let's hope.
It's that explicit.
Oh, we're in the right spot.
Good job, horse.
Okay.
We're looking for a ghost now, everybody.
We're looking for...
...a ghost on these roads.
We're looking for a ghost on these roads.
A ghost!
I'm also a ghost.
No, not me!
Not me.
Another ghost.
They just left this guy.
Where can I see him?
Ghost!
Ghost in the bottom right.
No!
Ghost!
If you guys see it, yell ghost.
I think that was my horse.
If you guys see it, ghost, yell ghost!
Follow the red marker.
It's not!
It's not that, you guys!
It's not the red marker!
Ghost!
Wait, where do you see it?
Wait, where do you see it, actually?
The ghost is scared of ghosts.
It's on the bottom right.
No!
Not me!
I want to see the ghost in the game!
He said that there was one, and then people said that this ghost was real.
The ghost on the path.
You need to specify non-made ghost.
I don't know if he's a made ghost or not.
I don't think the ghost is an active quest.
Or rather...
I don't think it was a quest.
There was just a guy that said that there was a ghost.
On this road.
He travels along the path, so he is easy to miss.
It's close to roads leading to Koro, not around the town.
So not this road?
Let's see.
So he's on the paths leading to Koro.
It's not a quest.
I think it's more like a random encounter, yeah.
That's not a ghost.
Time to make a Minto mod for Oblivion.
Oh no, this is the Wayne and Pry-
Are those the guys that want me to join their little...
Their thing?
The farmer boys?
Priory.
Wayne and Priory.
I feel like I'll never see him.
I feel like I'll never see the ghost.
Should be around under Paul Cave.
Wonderful.
A crumbling mine?
North East.
Oh, wait.
Is that not where I am?
He isn't near the town.
Travel the orange road.
Okay.
I guess we didn't travel this road.
Before we were like...
At night, so...
North East.
Come on.
My head in Shadow's Rest Cavern.
Oh my god.
Leave me alone.
Oh...
Gosh.
Don't attack my horse.
Oh my god.
You're pathetic.
It's a horse!
It's a horse.
Oh my god.
No!
I got my horse!
Stop it!
Oh my gosh.
My horse is also attacking him.
Take all my arrows back.
That guy was tough.
You were a tough bandit.
There he goes.
Sinking down the hill.
How come more important things...
Oh.
Oh, there he is.
How far can he go?
You start the Knights of the Nine questline, you'll eventually meet the ghost.
Really?
Reading the ghost is on the road that leads to Bruma from Coral.
That would be this road.
The orange road.
Maybe the ghost will run past us because we're...
Wait, what time is it?
Oh.
Enemies are nearby.
Well, he's dead.
He's a dead enemy.
How does that help me?
Maybe the ants are taking him.
I want to see how far he goes.
Maybe the ghost will run past us because we're...
Oh, my horse.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't mean to.
Oh.
He's better now.
Have you seen the ghost?
Oh.
He's ignoring me.
What is it, citizen?
Have you...
Have you seen the ghost?
Talk to me.
Oh, wow.
What an angle.
I don't know who was behind the Emperor's murder.
We've already ruled out the Dark Brotherhood.
So is this something...
Worse?
I'm gonna be a part of that soon.
Carry on.
Okay.
I'm looking for a ghost.
This guy is still slowly but surely sinking down the hill.
All this just for one ghost.
Excited to get to Duke but now realizing they're going to be shooting.
Oh.
Wait, what?
Brandon, I hope everything's okay.
Wait.
Is it here?
Wait, no.
Is this the cavern?
Wait, something...
Oh, we went up that...
We went over this earlier before, no?
Calm down, bro.
Alright.
I say...
Well, it's only 1am.
We might still catch him, no?
Oh.
Oh, ghost.
What are we doing now?
Looking for a ghost.
But I think I'm actually...
Wait.
Oh, it's 1am.
We have to wait until midnight...
For the...
Thieves Guild.
Where's the cave at?
Glad...
Gladymist Cave.
Hmm...
Yeah...
Oh, that's right.
It was, uh...
Oh, that's a dog.
No.
No!
I was hoping he wouldn't see me.
Just keep running.
What if I fast travel away?
Will the dog also fast travel?
Actually...
Wait.
Can I get to...
Oh, gosh.
Okay, horse.
We're going to...
Horse.
Alright, let's go, horse.
Let's go.
Good job, horse.
We're going to the Imperial City.
I give up.
I think the...
I think we lost the dog.
Awesome.
Oh, good job, horse.
Oh, that's an imp.
Ignore?
Ignore and go downwards?
Oh, gosh.
Why is the music getting worse?
Keep going.
Where are we?
Guys, I'm lost.
There's a deer.
Excuse me.
And...
A path has been found.
I think.
Is that dog still chasing after me?
I wonder where he's at.
Oh, God!
He's right there!
He's on my tail!
Oh, my God!
He's persistent.
Why can't you outrun fellas in this game?
Oh, my gosh.
Surely we'll run into a member of the Imperial...
Everything.
That's a bandit.
No?
That's a person.
That's a bandit!
Run!
Help!
Okay, he's gonna get the dog.
Nice.
I win by doing nothing.
Wait, why did that guy stop chasing me?
GG easy.
Are you a friend or what?
He's not a bandit.
Who are you?
Oh, I almost killed you!
Yeah,
I mean...
Be seeing you.
Just a guy.
Anyway...
Very nice.
Where are we?
Oh, okay.
We're right outside the city.
Perfect.
Let's go this way.
Why?
Why is he...
What is that guy doing outside?
Wandering?
There are bandits around here.
Run!
Culp!
Wa...
Wa net in.
Oh...
How cute!
Wait!
I think this is where I stole the horse.
I mean, borrowed the horse.
I think this is where I got the horse from and then I fled.
I think so.
Aw...
Aw, good memories.
What's that fire over there?
Let's go check it out.
Yeah!
The stables!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Aw...
You think they remember me?
I found the ghost!
Ever need to sell expensive stuff?
The lady in the mystic emporium.
Off the imperial city has tons of money and bad merchant skill.
Oh, nice!
Wait, where was that fire coming from?
Oh, right here.
Oh, a cave!
Oh, boy.
Someone was getting lady here.
Carrots and beer.
What was that?
What are these?
Why'd they throw their apples into the sea?
I gotta be careful around here.
There's mud crabs.
Those guys suck.
Oh, I stepped on the carrot.
Oh.
Carrots and beer.
My favorite.
Kinda wish I could've had that pastry I got earlier.
So I need to go...
to that way.
Maybe I should go inside.
Always take a pastry break.
Maybe.
No.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure this is where I took...
got the horse.
Borrowed.
They'll watch over my horse.
I wonder if they remember me.
Wow, let's see!
Oh, my gosh!
There are so many horses here!
And they couldn't let one...
They couldn't let me have one?
Look at how pretty this one is.
Oh, there's a guy here.
Are you watching over the horses?
Oh, hello.
I'm Brilis Gawi.
And no, we don't sell horses.
But we do eat well.
The stables are owned by an orc.
And you know...
Orcs and horses...
What does that mean?
Goodbye.
Why don't you sell any of them?
There's so many.
What do you do with all these horses?
What do they mean with...
Oh, they eat the horses?
I thought they just ate dogs.
I'm locking you in here.
I'm hungry.
Oh, sorry.
Hello.
Oh, a snack.
Snakwabura.
Owner and proprietor.
We board horses and...
Well, we don't actually sell horses.
Anymore, that is.
Why not?
You got anything useful for me?
What can I interest you in?
I'd like...
Armor.
What kind of armor can we get?
Wait.
I'm an elf, technically.
I'm an elf, technically, so...
The fabled horse armor.
Which one should I get?
Seal armor or elven armor?
Elven armor is fancier.
Say no more.
Here you are.
Just like I promised.
Thanks again for all the help.
Oh.
Armored my horse for free.
From now on, she will outfit any legally owned...
Any legally owned horse that I bring to her with steel or elven armor.
For 500 gold.
Pricey.
Let's see.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I'm closing my eyes.
How does she look?
Oh.
Wow.
This is...
Oh, I didn't expect it to be so...
Gaudy.
It's so...
Oh, wow.
Paid to win horse.
You guys have...
I have no ill feelings towards the armor.
That will be $5, please.
We said it was fancy.
This is like...
Something else.
No.
I remember being here.
Okay.
Let's just follow the red arrow.
There.
This way.
What is it, citizen?
Nothing.
Don't bother me.
I don't know any colors.
Especially I don't know a color gray.
I think the word is ornate.
Yeah.
Oh.
What am I doing?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, hold on.
I think I just discovered a cat claw in my chair.
I was like, something's poking me.
I think there's a cat claw stuck in my chair.
I nearly forgot.
Happy Mother's Day.
Oh, oh, oh.
You have my ear, citizen.
Goodbye.
It might have been...
Blue Tidal has been sleeping in my chair lately.
It might have been him.
Uh...
This way?
This way.
Yeah, cats shed...
Them all the time.
It's nothing...
Unusual.
To just be walking around and seeing a...
A cat claw on my floor.
Happens all the time.
Oh!
Oh, this is not my horse.
This is plain boring horse.
So it's still technically night time, I think.
This is where I need to wait?
Or...
Over on the other side.
How do I get around?
Oh, here we go.
You have my ears, making a lot of money for the tribes and elsewhere.
And a lot of that is going to the Rinridra Kryn.
If the Empire isn't going to stop the skooma trade, who will?
Goodbye.
Oh, hey, sweet lady of Weyrest.
Oh, hey, sweet lady of mine.
I'll see you again.
Yes, I'll see you again.
Sweet lady of Weyrest so fine.
Speak...
Oh, God.
Oh, sweet lady of Weyrest.
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, there he is.
I need to speak to you.
He's a pirate!
I ain't got nothing to say to your fancy chance.
So why don't you mind your own business, huh?
Wait, you sang your little shanty at me.
Wait, I wanna be a pirate too.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, they're terrible.
Don't board the boat.
Oh, hey, sweet lady of Weyrest.
Oh, hey, sweet lady of mine.
I'll see you again.
Yes, I'll see you again.
Sweet lady of Weyrest so fine.
What happens if I board the boat?
Oh!
Understandable.
Stay away!
Get him!
He's puny!
Puny ancus!
Get puny anus!
Oh, God.
Okay.
Run away!
I wanna be a pirate!
I wanna be a pirate, please!
They can't swim.
That's why they ride boats.
Wait, no!
I want my guy to stay alive so he'll sing for me!
Wait, don't kill them!
No!
She's even got buckled shoes.
Oh, sweet lady of mine.
How do I...
How do I reload?
Silver arrows!
Oh!
Oh my God.
I'm only asking for a single coin.
Oh, wait.
This must be where we see him then.
Lighthouse.
There should be an autosave.
I already autosaved.
I wanna auto-reload so that they aren't dead.
F9.
Let's see if this works.
Thank you!
There once was a hardy young lad of the sea.
A red god of courage and honor was he.
Sail on my Cyrus Sail on.
Beautiful, isn't she?
The Marie Elena.
Yeah.
Damn fine ship.
With a damn fine crew.
I should know.
I'm her first mate.
Malvulus is my name.
So believe me when I tell you we don't like it when people snoop around in our affairs.
Oh.
You get near that ship and my men will run you through.
I wanna join you.
Let me join the pirates.
What's here?
What's this little area?
It's cute.
It's shack.
Hmm.
Okay.
I'm going to let...
The game...
We gotta...
Oh gosh.
What's this?
Interesting.
We gotta meet the guys...
Somewhere over here?
Who are you?
What can I do for you?
Nice.
Accessories.
Oh, you can't do...
You can't do anything for me.
Farewell.
What's in here?
Nothing.
Okay.
Oh, ooh.
We're meeting in...
Here?
At midnight?
Is this where it is?
Yeah, I'm gonna let the game run.
And I'm gonna go out to get my...
My pastry.
And then I'm gonna eat it.
It has to be midnight.
We'll just let the day...
Fade away.
But I'm gonna get my...
Cuz I gotta put it on a plate and it's kinda messy.
So...
Let me go get that.
I'm getting kinda hungry, so...
Hmm.
A little short break, everybody.
No!
I forgot my drink.
Dang it.
I just sat down with everything.
I forgot my drink.
What's happening?
Why is the camera going around in a circle?
What the?
Oh, is that like when it dies?
When it's idle?
Is that what it dies?
It's just cinematic.
Fancy.
What time is it?
Only 8am.
It circles your character.
Ooh.
Let me go get my drink.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Oh, no.
Alright.
I wanna see it.
I'm not gonna touch it.
I wanna see it go idle.
Sashkin, thank you so much for the vibe.
Good to...
Thank you.
Okie dokie.
Time to try this.
But more properly.
Since I got a plate this time.
Ow.
Mmm.
I'd rather not.
Thank you so much for the tengeton.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
The cream is so good.
It's like a...
Tart-ish.
Tart?
Mmm.
Oh, it's so yummy.
Me.
Oh...
Did you get it again?
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, it would.
Oh, here it is.
Yum man.
Wow, the cream is so good.
I guess it's just like a normal whipped cream, but... it's like a little more... it's not so... it's not so... like, whippy.
It's a little more hard.
Are we supposed to look like E.T.
with hair?
Oh, yeah, this is E.T.E.N.A.
Oh, whoops.
See?
E.T.E.N.A.
Hold on, I have some more fruit.
For my fruit salad.
That I just dropped in my lap.
No!
Ooh!
Ooh, it's cold.
Yummy.
I have to wash my pants now.
Let's go talk to somebody.
Since there were people here.
We can go into somebody's house.
A bed?
We can go into somebody's house again.
Or...
E.T.E.N.A.'s shack.
Oh, empty sack.
This one's not empty.
Oh?
Is this...
This could be E.T.E.N.A.'s...
place.
Wait, the fire's already lit.
Wait.
One of the shacks is for sale by the real estate agency.
Oh!
E.T.E.N.A.'s new home!
Oh, my God.
This is so...
ASMR, no?
Oblivion BGM.
Fireplace crackling.
Minto eating her pastry.
Mech joined a pirate crew once.
Mech did not recommend it.
No one told Mech the sea is wet.
But she says your name is a liar.
Get deep, scorn, hollow.
Where's that?
If you put items in most containers, they'll disappear.
Only owned homes in a certain inn room are safe.
Oh, no!
Oh, God.
Bottom right of the map.
We'll go there.
Sorry for that food break, guys.
Sorry, sorry.
Containers regenerate their contents is why.
Oh, that's exciting to know.
So I can always take the same gold.
Eventually.
I can always take a few
days to respawn in-game, right?
A few in-game days?
In-game.
Oh, God.
This is so yummy.
I just had some pizza slices myself.
Mmm, pizza.
I wish I got pizza.
I didn't even get pizza on Pizza Friday.
Probably shouldn't have pizza every Friday.
And then I get a big pizza.
Because it's the cheapest for some reason.
Oh, my gosh.
Thank you so much for the 15th gift.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I get pizza.
A big pizza.
Because it's cheaper that way.
And then...
I end up having pizza for like four days.
That sounds awesome.
I don't know.
I mean, it's not bad.
But it's not...
It's not exactly what I want.
Why can't I just get a small pizza for cheap?
I have pizza every Friday in college at a club event for years.
And I couldn't look at it for years after.
Right?
Yeah, I imagine.
Banana.
No, because the place that I get my pizza always has a deal.
But it's like the two toppings for a large pizza.
And I get the two toppings.
Or it's like several toppings for a large pizza.
I get the couple toppings.
But I want like a small pizza.
I don't want a large pizza.
It's just for me.
Otherwise, it's gonna be like twice the price.
Of what I get.
Even though I...
I...
Want...
I just want a small...
Oh well.
Still don't see the issue.
Because I don't want to eat so much pizza.
That's the issue.
I...
I want to eat only a small amount of pizza.
And then be like...
Okay.
If I eat so much pizza...
I'll feel...
Terrible.
Such a nuisance to pay double for properly sized porridge.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Okay.
What I'll do...
I'll eat what I want...
And I'll leave the leftovers outside.
And then you guys can...
Come over and nibble on the rest.
First come, first serve.
Outside the maid cafe.
You're not a ninja turtle?
You can freeze pizza.
I never thought of that.
I never thought of doing that.
My mom freezes everything.
Yesterday she gave me frozen croissants.
And I was like...
How long have these been in there?
Actually, my sister had a discussion with my mom yesterday.
She was like...
Mom, I went and cleared out your fridge.
You had things from 1999 in there.
Or no, it was the pantry.
And my mom was like...
It was good cake mix.
Can you hear?
Can you hear the grape?
Vintage cake.
Yeah, pretty much.
No?
Okay, good.
Don't listen to me eat.
I get self-conscious.
Alright, I'm almost done.
We wasted a sufficient amount of time.
Not money.
Ever eaten an art?
Oh, like the MRE?
No, I've always wanted to try one, but...
I'm scared.
You was in the chat joking about the idea of saving leftover pizza by freezing.
What do you mean joking?
I used to eat MREs a few times a year.
I...
Like...
He was following me.
He didn't come out.
I heard this place was abandoned.
Oh, okay.
I'm through talking to you.
I'm...
Likewise.
I'm the one who ended the conversation.
Jerk.
Okay.
I don't...
I'm not fired.
I quit.
Energy over here.
Hello.
Uh...
Hi.
Do I know you?
You say a beggar told you to seek me out?
Good enough for me, then.
The beggars are the eyes and ears of the Grey Fox.
Wait, no.
I got a letter.
He is the king of thieves in Syria.
You could think of him as our guilt master, although he would deny that title.
Uh...
Can I do...
Oh, mysterious note.
Ah, yes.
Another scoundrel who served time in an imperial jail.
The Grey Fox is offering you a chance to join the thieves' guild.
Yes.
Join the thieves' guild.
Everyone is here.
Let's begin.
Each of you is seeking membership in the thieves' guild.
The thieves' guild is not a myth.
We are followers of the Grey Fox, and I am his doyen.
Merely by finding me, you have passed the first test.
There's tests?
It's unusual for us to have three potential recruits at the same time.
Rather than the normal test of skill, I'm going to make this a contest.
Oh.
That's not fair.
Methredel, you know the rules.
However, for Amusei and the newcomer, let me state them clearly.
Whoever brings me the diary of Amantius Electus without killing him...
Amantius Electus.
I'll have it before sunrise.
Somewhere in the Imperial City, the beggars will help you locate it for a price.
I can sell you lockpicks if you need them.
Okay.
One more thing.
You cannot kill each other during this trial.
We may be thieves, but we're not murderers.
May the best thief win.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Can they also pickpocket me?
I spoke with Armand Kristoff, who is a member of the thieves' guild.
He offered me a chance to join the guild, but I have to compete against two other thieves.
Meth...
Methid...
And Amusei.
Whichever of us steals Amantius Electus' diary first will be inducted into the thieves' guild.
Somewhere in the Imperial City, he told me that the beggars might be able to help...
Oh, tell me where to find him.
Maybe he lives in the Elven Gardens District.
Oh, shoot.
Uh...
Oh.
Wait.
You've got my ear.
I'm faster than you?
You have my ear, Cecil.
Um...
Nope.
Uh...
How do I get inside?
To the city?
Nope.
How do I get inside to the city?
Wait, where'd she go?
Oh, no.
Wait, how do I get inside to the city?
Uh-oh.
Uh...
Oh, shoot.
I'm lost?
Wait!
I should've just followed her.
Here?
No?
Uh...
Maybe he lives in the Elven Gardens District.
How do I get inside the city?
Hold on.
I'm gonna make it my main quest.
Oh!
It is my main quest.
Here?
Speak.
Goodbye.
What?
Around the wall.
Are you...
For real?
Oh, I came from over here.
Ah!
I came from over here before.
That's why.
Oh, my God.
Oh, yeah.
There he goes, too.
Maybe he lives in the Elven Gardens District.
Ugh!
I forgot.
Oh, my God.
Oh, wait.
Oh, nope.
That's a horse.
I thought that was her.
Oh, wait.
I'm gonna find somebody first.
Before you.
Gosh, I don't know where anybody's at.
Where are you going?
Excuse me!
She went right into his house!
Where is it?
In here?
Don't pickpocket me.
Run.
What is it, citizen?
Nothing.
I'm a good citizen.
Read it.
Yeah, I need to.
Inventory.
Amantius Electus's Diary.
I've planted the seed of the drinkers.
Soon I shall know if my theories hold true.
The first shoots have appeared.
I must make sure to continue the precise schedule of nutrient solutions.
Small drinker fronds are clearly visible.
This is a critical time in their development.
I'm almost out of rat blood.
I'll have to catch some more of the filthy beggars.
The young plants are juveniles now.
I can see them waving as if in a breeze.
Although the air in my cellar is still as death.
I'm having a hard time catching any more cats.
I may have to start using dogs.
The damn drinker plants have a voracious apple.
Oh my gosh.
They're making Seymour.
Suddenly Seymour.
No.
Tui.
They're making.
They're making Tui.
The plant.
From the musical.
Feed me, Seymour.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Audrey too.
Pinto swiped it right in front of his eyes.
Oh my god, he's gonna turn into a plant.
Actually, I lied.
This is... this is Goosebumps.
My creations are refusing to feed.
As an experiment, I offered a drop of my own blood, which one of them drank greedily.
The other drinkers are beginning to wither.
I collected a bucket of human blood from the healers.
I had to pay her an exorbitant amount to keep her tongue still.
The drinkers are doing much better.
Am I doing the right thing?
The benefit of these plants to all of Kyra...
How do you say this place's name again?
Cyrodiil?
Cyrodiil, okay.
Is beyond doubt, but the price may be too high.
It is one of the most difficult decisions of my life.
I have destroyed my notes for how to hybridize drinkers.
I set the trays on the roof where the sun could strike them.
An hour after sunrise, they were all dead.
My attempt to create a hybrid of vampire and plant has failed.
They were just too dangerous.
Successfully pickpocketing an NPC.
Two parts grave... oh!
Now we know.
Two parts grave dust, one part ash salt mixed with human blood exposed to two hours of moonlight each night.
Running, running, running.
Oh!
Uh, are you not going or...?
Step aside!
I'm gonna win the right to join the guild.
You can't beat me.
You're going the frog way!
Okay.
Can I...
Oh, I was gonna say, can I get on the boat now?
But they're all still awake.
To what do I owe this pleasure?
Are you confused?
No.
I've got the diary.
Wait.
I've got it.
Wait, I've got...
I got it.
You scared me!
You have earned the right to join the thieves guild.
Thank you.
You now owe your loyalty to our guild master, the Grey Fox.
He has three rules you must follow.
I thought it was gonna be a prompt that said the diary, you know, like...
Three rules.
First, never steal from another member of the guild.
Second, never kill anyone on the job.
This is not the Dark Brotherhood.
Animals and monsters can be slain if necessary.
He's just repeating exactly what I read before.
First, don't steal from the poor.
The peasants and beggars are under the personal protection of the Grey Fox.
Particularly here on the waterfront.
Wait, so...
It said don't murder on the job, but...
What if I'm not doing a job?
What if I'm just...
Wanting to murder?
Then it's fine.
Yippee!
He's been around forever.
Must be 300 years or more since he took charge.
I'm not sure he's even human.
I...
I mean...
If he's 300 years old...
Recreational murder is a-o-kay.
He's a captain of the Imperial Watch.
He is pursuing a personal vendetta against the Thieves Guild and the Grey Fox.
Two years ago, I made a fool out of him when he tried to arrest me.
Lex has never forgotten it.
Hehehehe.
Have you heard about Kavaj?
They say that Deirdre came from Oblivion and burned the whole city to the ground.
Yeah, I was there.
The best source of information are the beggars.
Their eyes and ears seem to be everywhere.
I thought it.
However...
I thought it would be like...
Sorry, you've seen that the diaries in another castle.
I won't tell you anything for free.
At least not anything true.
Not anything true?
What about...
Yeah, special...
Special jobs.
You need more experience before I can use you on a condition job.
Angar tells me that you haven't turned in much loot yet.
When you've contributed enough to the guild coffers by selling stolen items to Angar, I might have something for you.
Where do I meet Angar?
Wait, where do I meet him?
We're thieves, not masons or scribes.
Oh, independent thievery.
Look, you're on your own as a thief.
Go find a likely looking house.
Pace the joint to see when the owner is gone.
When he leaves, you break in and steal some stuff.
You don't need special permission or orders to do that.
So true.
However, you will find that you can only sell stolen property to one of our guild fences.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Most other merchants won't take hot merchandise.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So we all work alone?
Well, sometimes the guild gets a special commission.
You know, guaranteed pay to acquire certain items for special clients.
You should check in with your doyen every once in a while to see if there are any commission jobs available.
I'd like to hear it.
Sorry, I'm using a blue bar.
Or...
Hmm...
Ok.
Yay!
Well, that lady led us right to it.
Shadow hide you.
That lady led us right to it.
So...
Um...
Heh, heh, heh boo boo to you everybody else.
Oh...
Now that we're here...
Ask about the guild to learn where your fence is.
Oh, okay.
Good.
Oh.
Oh, puny.
Um, about the guild.
Yeah, I need to know where a fence is, so I can...
Oh, what if I do kill someone?
What if I... murder... when I'm having... just a good... what if it's just, you know...
Cloud, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Actually, I have a mission right now.
I gotta go kill somebody.
The best fences are only available to the higher-ranked Thieves' Guild members.
Here's a list of who you can use.
Hmm.
Angar.
Angar lives in Bruma.
Okay, okay.
He doesn't have much money, but he's the only place you can sell hot property if you are new to the Thieves' Guild.
Okay, I'm new.
I just joined tonight.
Shadowhide you.
We only got that one guy.
Okay.
Now, we need to go here.
So to quest, we're gonna do...
A knife in the dark.
Wait.
Did that...
Did that do it?
Oh, it did.
Okay, good.
Oh.
Oh, it's... wait.
Hmm?
Why is it...
Why is it telling me to go this way?
I hope I made myself clear the first time.
If you get near that ship, you will end up dead.
Now get out of my face.
I wasn't talking to you, lady!
It sends you through the city.
Oh.
Well, we need to go down.
Maybe it's telling us to go around the city.
That's so weird.
Hmm.
I could just swim.
I know how to swim.
We could swim the whole...
Oh, hey, sweet lady of Wayrest.
Oh, hey, sweet lady of mine.
I'll see you again.
Yes, I'll see you again.
Sweet lady of Wayrest.
So fine.
I hear a nerd root.
I hear it.
Wait, where are you?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, sweet lady of Wayrest.
Oh, sweet lady of mine.
Did you just say nerd?
Oh, well, we have to abandon our horse to swim.
But I think it's worth it, no?
It's way faster.
It's way faster to just swim.
There's nowhere to fast travel this way, though.
Like if I swim.
Watch out for slaughter fish.
Oh, that's right.
There were that...
The first time I played, there was just that one guy.
That one fish.
But he wasn't doing anything.
I think they're useless.
Mudcrabs.
Those guys are annoying.
I hate those the most.
Back I'll walk with my bow.
What's this?
Tower stone.
You're marked by a special fate.
You rule your destiny.
Do you choose to steer by the stars of the tower?
Yeah.
The stars of the tower shine upon you.
You gain the warden key and master's hand greater powers.
What did that do?
Gives you a daily spell.
New spells.
Neat.
Okay.
Now we go this way.
Oh, lady of mine.
Oh, sweet lady.
Bah, bah, bah, bah, bah.
So sweet lady of so fine.
Wait, it changed my lucky stars?
Wait, everybody's giving me different information.
Does it give me a spell?
Or does it change my...
I feel like it would tell you if it changed your star.
It's a separate buff.
Okay.
This isn't Skyrim chat.
You can't change your star.
Oh.
You guys are getting confused.
You guys are silly.
You're getting confused.
Different game.
What time is it anyway?
Let's see.
Oh.
Enemies are nearby.
Where?
Enemy nearby.
Am I being pursued by a mudcrop?
Oh, my sneak increase.
It scared me.
Do the deer count as enemies?
Because...
I'm starting to think that's the case.
There we go.
Okay, it's 4 a.m.
And I guess we're...
Whoa.
Wait, I'm stuck.
There it is.
That's not a door to oblivion, is it?
Oh.
Oh, come on.
Dog.
Oops.
I'm so stupid.
There we go.
Wait, why is there a portal to oblivion here?
Wait, why is it telling me to go here?
Huh?
It's near the inn.
No kidding.
Wait, will things come out and attack the daedra...
Oh, shoot.
I answered my own question.
Ah!
You caught him on fire.
Friendly fire.
Oh.
Why is it red?
What's happening?
What's going on?
Because I'm close to the gate.
Oh.
Okay, let's, uh...
Let's go the long way around.
Um...
I didn't expect...
Oh, golly.
Okay, I'm just trying to murder a man.
Ill-o-men.
Where is it at?
Oh, here it is.
Who am I murdering here?
Rufio.
A man named Rufio.
That's not our guy, is it?
Hello.
Average.
Wait, I'm allowed in here.
Wow, this is the...
Most dingy...
Inn I've ever seen, ever.
No wonder the inn has that name.
What the?
Um...
There's no one by the name Rufio here.
Oh my god.
Don't leave.
Don't do that.
Stop it.
Stop.
You're doing this on purpose.
No!
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Oh, no.
Who are you?
What do you want?
I ain't done nothing.
Uh...
Oh, but you have, Rufio.
No, please.
I didn't mean to do it.
You understand me?
She struggled.
I...
I told her to just stay still, but she wouldn't listen.
I had no choice.
What...
What did you do?
Stop...
Stop moving so fast!
Stop it!
Stop...
Stop moving so fast!
Rufio!
The next time I sleep in a location he deems secure...
He will visit me once again.
Well, thanks for unlocking this for me.
Why was he...
Why was he dancing around so crazy, like?
What...
What did he do?
Rufio!
Maybe...
You really did deserve that.
I think he actually deserved that...
A lot.
I'm just looking.
Dead to you.
Boo-boo, Rufio.
He's not gonna be mad at me when I come up here, right?
Oh, golly.
Wait.
Open?
Open.
There we go.
Stop right there, criminal scum.
Nobody breaks the law on my watch.
I'm confiscating your stolen goods.
I didn't!
Now pay your fine or it's off to jail.
No!
How much is it?
That's only 25.
Wait.
He caught you pickpocketing.
No way.
They don't even care that I murdered him.
I feel like I should reload.
Honestly.
I think I'm gonna...
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna reload.
That's too bad.
I didn't even mean to pickpocket him.
I was hoping you'd resist arrest.
Okay.
I didn't even think...
Ugh!
I didn't even think I was...
I'm gonna reload.
Ugh!
Um...
It was an auto-save.
This one, yes.
Okay.
I was like, wait a second.
Wait, use the blade this time.
Why?
Oh, you're doing it with the blade.
The Brotherhood gives you bonuses.
Oh, okay.
Good to know.
Who are you?
What do you want?
I ain't done nothing.
Oh, but wait.
No one hides from Sithis.
Oh, please, no.
I can pay you.
Name your price.
Anything.
Please, just let me live.
He doesn't sound very convincing.
Oh!
Wee!
He didn't even yell.
Good job, Rufio.
Good job dying so quietly.
I can sleep here?
Is this place deemed...
Oh, was there anything in here?
I don't think so, no.
I don't think there was anything worth it in here.
That was so easy.
Try this bed.
This one?
Free bed.
Yeah, let's use it.
Wait, I'm gonna save.
I'm gonna sleep for...
Two hours.
Just a little nap, you know.
I sense a presence nearby.
So, the deed is done.
Yeah, he's right behind you.
How do I know this?
You'll find that the Dark Brotherhood knows a great many things.
For you are now part of the family.
My life for the Brotherhood!
Indeed.
For the slaying of Rufio was the signing of a covenant.
The manner of execution, your signature.
Rufio's blood.
The ink.
Nice.
As a speaker of the Black Hand, I directly oversee a particular group of family members.
You will join that group and fulfill any contracts given.
Let's go.
You must now go to the city of Chaitin Hall.
To the abandoned house near the eastern wall.
Enter the basement and attempt to open the black door.
Okay.
You will be asked a question.
Answer thusly.
Sanguine, my brother.
You will gain entrance to the sanctuary.
Once inside, speak with Ochiva.
Ochiva.
We must now take our leave of each other.
You and I.
For there is much work to be done.
I'll be following your progress.
Welcome to the family.
What did Rufio do?
Rufio lies dead.
Well done.
The family will now welcome you with open arms.
Okay.
Covenant.
Know this.
Every dark brother and sister is a child of Sithis.
He whom we call Sithis...
Yeah, Sithis!
Many other names.
Chaos, doom, discord.
Sithis is the void.
Yeah, Sithis!
We of the Dark Brotherhood serve the Night Mother.
A happy Mother's Day?
Who is the bride of Sithis.
The Night Mother rules her children with a terrible black hand.
The black hand is the ruling body of the Dark Brotherhood.
It is made up of one listener and four speakers.
Four fingers and a thumb, if you will.
Oh yeah, that's a hand.
As a member of the Dark Brotherhood, you must abide by the Five Tenants.
They are the laws that guide and protect us.
This guy is yapping.
Holy cow.
What's the Five Tenants?
The Five Tenants are as follows.
Okay.
Tenant One.
Never dishonor the Night Mother.
Okay.
To do so is to invoke the wrath of Sithis.
Tenant Two.
Never betray the Dark Brotherhood or its secrets.
Sometimes he has an accent.
To do so is to invoke the wrath of Sithis.
Okay.
Tenant Three.
Never disobey or refuse to carry out an order from a Dark Brotherhood superior.
To do so is to invoke the wrath of Sithis.
Is my OTP a joke to you?
Never steal the possessions of a Dark Brother or Dark Brother.
To do so is to invoke the wrath of Sithis.
How do I know if they're a Dark Brother or Sister?
Tenant Five.
Never kill a Dark Brother or Dark Sister.
To do so...
Sorry, it's funny.
Is to invoke the wrath of Sithis.
For those...
So, okay.
So, basically...
In Fruits Basket...
The...
The show...
I really liked Yuki and Tohru together.
And I was just like...
Oh, but you know...
Like...
Rather...
Or rather...
I used to like...
Kyo and...
Wait...
Tohru...
Kyo and Tohru together.
But then...
I...
When I...
When I re-watched it...
I was like...
Oh, man.
I really like Yuki, actually.
But I know he's like...
The second lead.
So...
The second lead never gets with the person.
You know?
Like, it's never...
It never works out.
But rather than getting friend-zoned...
You know what happens with my second lead?
Yuki...
In Fruits Basket.
You know what happens to him?
He's just like...
Oh, yeah.
You know what?
I discovered something.
I don't just love Tohru Honda...
As a woman.
I love her as a mother.
And getting mother-zoned...
Might be the worst thing to ever happen.
I'm just...
You couldn't even just let him down lightly...
And let him move on.
No, no, no.
You had to have my...
My man was so perfect.
She would have picked him.
Probably not, actually.
But...
She was so perfect.
He was...
Or rather, he was so perfect...
That they had to give the whole ass excuse...
That he mother-zoned her...
So that...
I feel like we had this conversation before.
We have...
I was explaining it for people...
Who didn't understand...
Why...
I love you like a mother triggers me.
Dear sister...
I do not spread rumors.
I create them.
Wait.
Oh, okay.
I was gonna say...
That was...
That was still...
Like, lit up before.
Or lit up.
But I remember asking that before.
How does one best describe...
Our dread father?
Imagine a perfect...
Cloudless midnight...
She's like a...
She was like a mother to be naked...
Yuki Soba.
Cold as winterized...
Shrouding shadow.
That...
Is...
Sithis.
It was like...
And it was like...
In the most dramatic scene too...
Possible.
When it happened...
I was like...
This is...
Like...
Like there was just this...
Rush of...
He was just like...
She's like my mom.
And I was like...
You are now one...
With the Dark Brotherhood.
Visit Ochiva...
At the Chatham Hall Sanctuary...
And your...
New life...
Will begin.
Ochiva, Ochiva, Ochiva, Ochiva, Ochiva, Ochiva...
Okay, I'm following you out.
Oh.
When do I get...
That...
This?
When do I get the stealth camo?
When do I get this?
Ochiva, Ochiva, Ochiva...
Ochiva...
He's gone.
I'm so...
Well, I'll be a spotted snowbear.
A customer.
Yeah, I still got rooms.
What do you need?
A customer.
Rufio?
He's an old codger.
Been living here for a couple of weeks now.
If you ask me, he's hiding from something.
But what do I care?
He pays his tab.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
His room is downstairs.
In what I like to call...
The private quarters.
Why do you call it that?
Use that hatch in the floor over there.
But don't expect a warm reception.
It means OG sign.
Oh.
Way shrines of Arcade confer blessings of health on those who please the nine by righteous acts.
Okay.
Bye-bye.
Farewell, and tell your friends...
The...
I love mint as a boss of an army of men.
Oh.
Pleasant...
Pleasant weather we're having.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Goodbye, portal of oblivion for right now.
Let's check our map.
So we need to go to Ochilva.
He said it was on the bottom...
Right of the map?
No?
Ochilva.
East?
North?
Northeast?
I thought he said it was the bottom.
Oh, I'm west.
I'm an idiot.
Wait.
Ochilva.
Is this it?
No.
Your other...
I thought you said waste.
Okay.
Um, what I'm gonna do...
Is, uh...
Maybe we can fast travel to...
Like...
Fort Eurasek.
Because I feel like I've...
Well, maybe I haven't traveled all over.
I'm gonna travel...
No.
I'm not gonna travel to the prison.
I think that's bad luck.
I'm gonna...
Nah, I'll travel to the Fort Eurasek.
Yeah, yeah.
That's fine.
Yeah, been there if I have a marker like that.
Oh.
Hello, goblin.
Oh, that's the wrong weapon.
Wait, I've been...
I need to use my...
Oh, wait.
No.
Both of them are fine.
Oh.
Did you see that ghosting?
That's crazy.
Where's my horse?
A horse?
That's not my horse.
I was about to say horse.
Wait, where's my horse?
What race is Eetina?
Eetina is a wood elf.
Wait, where's my horse?
You guys said my horse would fast travel with me.
I was told that no matter where I traveled, if I fast traveled, my horse would be there.
Only certain areas.
Oh, we're changing the rules, aren't we, huh?
That's fine.
We can run.
We are fighting dreamers.
Fighting dreamers.
Oh, my God.
It's a fight you can't.
No, I was just singing a song.
Please.
I don't want to fight.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, my gosh.
Please.
How does he have so much...
Oh, my God.
Holy cow.
I was singing Fighting Dreamers.
And then when I come up on him, he's like, if it's a fight, you want.
I'm so angry right now.
Oh, I think...
Oh, I forgot that I wasn't in first person.
So, I probably threw off my bow a little bit.
Okay.
We lost all those arrows.
That's fine.
He obliged.
Yeah, exactly.
I think I just keep following this road.
It'll be a bit of a journey, but we got time.
Oh, chiva, oh, chiva, oh, chiva.
We're heading to...
Oh, chiva.
This looks lovely.
You got little flowers here and a little entrance.
And my future home.
Up there on the...
On the hilly hilltop.
I want to go to there.
Roland's cabin.
Wow.
Oh.
Um, am I not allowed in?
I'm not a...
I'm not a petty thief.
I'm a legit thief.
They released a 20th anniversary version of that song last year.
Guys, I'm a genius at this...
No, I did it again!
No!
I don't know why I keep saying lick.
I just want to say lockpick.
I'm just trying to say lockpicky.
Oh my gosh.
John, thank you so much for the 50th.
Thank you.
Oh my goodness.
I can't stop saying it.
Hello.
I'm the hero of Kvatch.
You watch your tongue.
Um...
I'm so angry at myself.
Why can't I speak properly?
I don't know why I can't...
Oh, there's a little imp.
I think I can get him.
Got him!
Oops.
I should have crouched for the bonus.
Uh-oh.
Uh, here he comes.
Shoot.
Oh, shoot.
Oh!
Oh, he's right in front of me.
Oh, lordy coming.
I should have crouched for the sneak furnace.
But I told you I'd get him.
Oh, my gosh.
Arrow to the knee.
That's from Skyrim.
No.
Isn't that a Skyrim joke?
Baron Cave.
Discovered.
Yeah!
I used to be...
And then I took an arrow to the knee.
Wow.
Oh, my gosh.
Gorgeous.
Baron Cave.
No.
I want to join my...
My fellow brothers and sisters.
Oops.
Am I on the right path?
Yes.
Oof!
Roblox.
Oof.
One second.
Ducky ducky.
I see a bandit.
I see two bandits.
Stop moving.
Criminal scum.
Shoot.
Got his ass.
Dang it.
That was close.
Oh, this guy is tough.
Oh, gosh.
Take that.
Oh, wait.
Let me take your potion of sickness.
Nice job.
Thank you.
Bye.
I...
You guys.
I like sn...
I like sniping.
You know?
It's like my thing.
I like it.
Slap a scope on that bow.
I know.
I wish, right?
Wait, where are we?
Oh, we're here.
Wait, what's this path, though?
I just want to check it out real quick.
We need to go to Ochi-va.
Ochi-va, Ochi-va.
Ochi-va, Ochi...
Oh.
Knights of the Thorn Lodge.
Wow.
This place probably smelled nice.
Oh.
Uh.
Do you think they'll get mad at me if I go in?
Hmm.
Oh.
There's a repair hammer.
I'll take that.
Her enemies fear thine one-on-one unrest.
I still don't feel like...
I don't know if I can...
I don't know if I can kill that one guy in one hit, you know?
I'm trespassing.
What was that?
Is that me?
My bad.
Sorry.
Oh!
I think you should leave.
Um.
Why?
As the newest member of the Knights of the Thorn, I bid you welcome.
You just said I should leave!
I've heard that Hill the Thorn knows a lot about alteration.
I'm getting fixed messages here!
Should I leave?
Should I go?
What do you mean?
Farewell.
Bye-bye.
So I can...
look around a little bit?
He's following me.
I don't...
I think it's fine if I, like, you know...
He's monitoring me.
I'm not gonna...
I'm...
I'll be...
I'm being good.
Ooh, who's better is this?
It's fancy.
This is your last warning.
Get out, or I'll call the guards and have you arrested.
I don't want to be arrested.
Well, at least I went in.
We got the nicest possible guard.
He's going to report you.
We got the nicest possible guy...
to kick us out.
Is that a bandit down there, or...
a guard?
Wait, where'd he go?
This is...
Oh.
That is...
a guard.
Yeah.
You remind me of my homeland.
During the Blight.
Damn!
Vyna, I just met you!
If you want to buy a horse, go inside and talk to Tovis.
I don't want to give you any money.
I...
There were lights spotted at Sundercliff Watch.
That place was cursed by Mehrunes Dagon himself.
Best not to go there.
Stop talking!
She's so rude.
Alright, so we go inside.
Wait.
We go in, and we go to the black door, and then we ask for somebody.
Everyone's so rude.
It's an inn.
Wow, this place is so cute.
I lied.
Okay, this is my new favorite town.
Oh my god.
Everything's purple.
Everything is purple.
It's so pretty.
And look.
It reminds me.
Oh my gosh.
With the castle and the mountain, it reminds me of...
In...
Tokyo Disneyland.
There's a...
There's...
The castle.
And...
Uh...
If we're like...
Belle's part of the area.
It's the beast castle and stuff.
And it looks so similar to this.
This one is so pretty.
I want to live here.
Yes.
I'm gonna buy a house here.
Look at the graveyard.
Feels just like home.
You can get a house here?
Hot dog.
Wait, this door is not black.
Wait, I should go towards here.
Oh.
This is the place.
The music.
Bread loaf.
The waters of oblivion.
Alright, let's go knock on the door.
Wait, I don't remember who to ask.
Oh, what do I say?
Hold on.
Sanguine my brother.
Oh, we're talking to Ochiva.
I thought that was the place we needed to go.
Sanguine my brother.
Oh, flip side.
Empty.
I'm just like...
Oh, my bad.
I'm just looking around.
It's a abandoned house anyway.
Oh my god.
This feels like...
Hot dog indeed.
Here's some Pocky friends.
Sanguine...
Oh, I thought it was going to be multiple choice.
Sanguine my brother.
I've gained entrance into the Dark Brotherhood Sanctuary.
I must now speak with Ochiva.
Tadai ma.
Oh, there's a skelly here.
Greetings, greetings.
I am Ochiva, mistress of this sanctuary.
Lucian has told me all about you.
Let me welcome you to the Dark Brotherhood.
Hmm.
It is always a pleasure to welcome another Dark Sister into our ranks.
Truly, the night mother smiles upon her trusted daughters.
You stand now in our sanctuary.
May it serve as your new home, a place of comfort and security whenever the need arises.
Thank you.
When you're ready for work, go and speak with Vicente Valtieri.
He handles all assignments for new family members.
Vicente Valtieri.
But before you go, please, accept this gift from your new family.
A unique set of armor, lighter than normal leather and black as the void.
But I've kept you long enough.
Vicente is waiting.
You'll find him in his quarters.
Go now, my child, and may Sithis go with you.
Wait, I want to see our armor.
Go now, dear family member, and may the night mother wrap you in her cold, loving embrace.
Shrouded armor.
This is stylish.
Are you kidding me?
No, we can't wear the hood, though.
No, no, no.
This?
Oh, my gosh.
And the effects?
Oh, right.
Your E.T.
Yep, yep, yep.
Wait, this looks amazing, though.
Oh, sorry.
Wait, sorry.
Sorry.
I didn't realize it was a full suit.
A little pocket change for you to buy some more sussy knot, save for streaming cream pastry.
Stop!
Thank you, though.
Dark guardian.
Oh, my gosh.
We get to see a skelly up close.
He's even wearing...
We're wearing the same outfit.
Wait.
I am honored by your presence.
How can Ochiva be of assistance?
I'm looking...
Wait, who am I talking to?
You?
No.
Wait.
I wish to welcome you to this sanctuary, my newest sister.
Oh, my gosh.
Thanks, fam.
I've heard so much about you.
You have?
Welcome to our family.
Sneaking suit acquired.
Yeah.
Oh, whoa.
Training room?
What's that?
Oh, my gosh.
How cute!
What's that?
What are these?
Oh.
Oh, wow.
Crystal ball.
Stuff to hit.
Yeah.
We can actually train in here.
It's so fun.
A zero tragedy.
French.
I like it down here.
I've heard so much about you.
What's the point?
Why should anyone bother with all that sneaking and skulking?
I like sneaking and skulking.
You are a life taker for the Dark Brotherhood.
Our very existence relies on shadow and deception.
Do you not value our secrets?
Yes, yes.
Of course, I value our secrets.
And I have never betrayed them.
But using stealth to kill, it's just so...
weak.
What?
But brother, what of the contracts that require subtlety?
You must at least strive to earn the bonuses that are offered.
Bonuses.
Ha ha ha ha.
Useless, I say.
Gold and magical trinkets are no substitute for the freedom to slaughter anyone I please, at any time.
That's fair.
Oh, Gogrin.
Your methods may be crude, but your heart is always in the right place.
There you are.
Welcome.
I like your armor, mister, but you're not matching like the rest of us.
Wait, who are you?
It is an honor to make your acquaintance.
Hello.
I'm trying to meet the person that will give me a quest.
Get away from me.
Oh.
If it isn't the newest member of the family.
Makes me want to talk to you more.
Let's get one thing straight.
The tenants prevent me from killing you.
But I don't have to like you.
I'll sell you equipment, but only because Ochiva is making me.
This family doesn't need any outsiders.
I'm part of the family.
Purchasing spells.
Foul smelling ape.
I'm an elf.
You again?
I thought I'd made it clear.
I am not looking for a friend.
Wait, now I really want to be his friend.
If you're here to buy or sell something, get on with it already.
Let's see.
Wait.
Oh, I can't even.
I can't even.
This position is actually quite high.
No?
For someone who's so upset-y.
Spaghetti.
He's just a little tsundere man.
Bow of infernal frost.
Fire damage on strike.
Frost damage.
Arrow of cowardice.
Demoralize on strike.
Oh, boy.
Golly, guys.
More steel arrows.
We can buy some here.
We can buy the five tenants.
I see this.
I don't have all day.
Hurry up.
Okay, okay.
Wait.
Can I... Can you buy things?
I see this.
I don't have all day.
Hurry up.
Can he buy the things that I've stolen?
No.
Oh, wait.
I'm at the wrong guild.
Foul-smelling ape.
Rude, kitty cat.
For some reason, you think that a sleeping slab...
For some reason, you think the Dark...
The Dark Brothers Guild would also be fine with stolen items.
But, oh...
It doesn't say that it's...
Note to Ochiwa.
What does that say?
I'm nosy.
Where is it?
There it is.
Ochiwa.
Damn that young fool, Antoinetta, and her experimental recipes.
As if the stench of her cooking weren't bad enough.
Last week, she made a particularly offensive dish consisting of mandrake, onions...
Dot, dot, dot...
And garlic!
Oh, he's a vampire!
He's a vampire!
Garlic!
I have told her repeatedly of the danger this plant poses to me, but she has obviously not heeded my warnings.
It is strange, this reaction I have to garlic.
In all my wanderings, in all my research, I have never encountered another vampire thusly affected.
It is true that some popular lore holds that all vampires have an inherent weakness to garlic, but this is simply not the case.
My situation, as far as I can tell, is unique.
If I were to somehow come into contact with garlic, if it in some way came to be on my person, the results could be catastrophic.
I would most certainly suffer from a loss of strength and stamina.
And fear my resistance to magic would be nearly completely nullified.
So please, Ochiwa, as mistress of this sanctuary, I beg you to keep Antoinetta on a tighter leash.
I love her as a sister.
Of course.
But cannot be held accountable for my actions, should she continue to disregard my own personal safety.
The tenants clearly state that one family member may not kill another.
But I don't need to remind you there is no restriction against draining Antoinetta of a few pints of precious life's blood.
Certain Dark Brotherhood members have some very funny bug.
Hopefully you will see it.
It's a very shiny forehead.
Oh.
Let's put this back.
He's just staring at me.
I don't need it.
There we go.
Ah, here you are.
So good to finally meet you.
Warmest greetings to you.
I trust you've already spoken with Ochiwa?
Yes.
I am Vicente Valtieri.
I provide assignments for all new family members.
He's bald!
Please, do not let my appearance unnerve you.
The needs and tenets of the Dark Brotherhood come before my own needs as a vampire.
Now, if you're ready to get to work, I can provide you with your first contract.
Yes, please.
Wait.
The bald is a- Is a bug?
He's not supposed to be bald!
He wasn't bald in my game!
I thought it- I thought it suited his character!
I just-
It comes back!
Oh my gosh!
I was stricken with vampirism 300 years ago, while on an expedition deep into the ashlands of Vardenfell.
For nearly a hundred years I hunted in secret, until the Dark Brotherhood- Oh, I'm crying!
It's so funny!
Now I have a family that accepts and even values my unique gift.
Sometimes it comes back!
Perhaps in the future, when I feel you have earned the right- I can't believe he's supposed to have it!
To become a hunter of the night.
Give me a contract!
A contract is a secret pact one enters into with the Dark Brotherhood.
They provide us with gold, and we remove someone from existence.
A contract is fulfilled by a skilled assassin, such as yourself- I'm skilled!
Who keeps the Dark Brotherhood's end of the bargain.
So it has always been.
While carrying out a contract, you may have the opportunity to earn a bonus if certain parameters are met.
Yes, sir.
Now, let's begin, shall we?
I'm not sure how you feel about pirates, but you've got to kill one.
Wait, wait!
A captain, in fact.
Wait!
On his ship.
Surrounded by his crew.
Interested?
The guys from before?
It is time.
Excellent.
Here is what you must do.
Go to the waterfront district of the Imperial City.
There you will find a ship named the Marie Elena.
Board the ship and find its captain, Gaston Tussaud.
He'll be in his cabin.
Eliminate Tussaud in any manner you see fit.
The pirates have been moving a lot of cargo on board lately.
You may be able to smuggle yourself on board in one of the packing crates.
Just a wax.
And one more thing.
Get into the habit of asking your fellow family members about any current contract.
Their insight may prove invaluable.
I don't want to ask.
Farewell, sister.
I want to hope that maybe his hair comes back.
Oh, wow.
Save and reload.
Yeah, let's try it.
Wait, hold on.
I want to see what's in here.
Oh, living quarters.
Let's take a nap.
Maybe we take a nap.
A paintbrush.
They're quite art.
Oh!
Oh.
Skimmer.
I almost...
I almost instinctually...
attacked him.
My voice is starting to get a little bit icky, so...
I'm gonna take a nap.
For...
Uh...
Five hours.
Sleepy sleep.
Wait.
Oh.
But it's not stealing.
Oh my god, it's all five of them.
Easy!
Open easy lock!
Wait, can I take all these?
I just saw a picture of the dude.
He honestly looks better bald.
No kidding!
Yeah, I'm...
I'm god at...
Lock picking.
Yeah!
I'm actually pretty good.
Oh,
dang it!
I almost had it!
So this will judge if you steal from another...
other members.
Actually...
But it's not in the red.
Doesn't...
It only counts as stealing if it's red.
Oh...
It doesn't actually count.
Okay, you guys are scaring me.
Ah, so close.
Gop, gop, gop.
Pickpocking.
No!
Some more!
Say lock picking ten times fast.
Sithis allow it.
Sithis should allow it because I'm being so cool...
about it, you know?
If I were to pickpocket, that's one thing.
There you are.
Welcome.
I'm welcome.
It is an honor to make your acquaintance.
Why was this letter?
Shopping list?
I've been meaning to speak with you.
Of course.
What is it?
I've been meaning to ask you about your last contract.
I'm eavesdropping.
I heard there were some...
complications.
Ah, yes.
That was quite a situation I got myself into.
I've heard so much about you.
But I have to admit...
Welcome to our family.
I've had a bit of fun cleaning up my own mess.
You're truly an asset to this sanctuary.
Here's hoping all of our contracts work out that well.
Ah, well...
I suppose I should get...
Oh.
Sithis be with you, brother.
I like the rat that comes around.
Scammer.
Well, guys.
I think I'm gonna call it here.
Next time we'll do our contract.
And...
Let's go see if the guy has grown hair.
We have to find him.
We have to go find him.
Where did they all go?
Go back.
Maybe he's in his room again.
Uh...
We're in here?
Skelly boy, so cute.
No?
Where'd he go?
Where did he go?
Everyone's talking about your latest exploits.
Not only did you eliminate the target, but his six Imperial Legion escorts as well.
Whoa!
Most impressive.
All right, so I may have gotten a bit careless, but the contract was fulfilled, wasn't it?
In the end, that's all that matters.
Sometimes I wonder how you survive it all without me being there to watch your back.
Well, I should return to my duty.
Why?
Oh, you wanted to hug me?
Is that what you just said?
So, your first contract.
No chance for a bonus, huh?
That's all right.
You're better off.
Who needs magic items when you've got raw skill?
And the great thing about killing a target up close and personal is you can talk to them before you do it.
You know, say something scary.
For example, this one time I had a contract to kill a little Nord girl at her birthday party.
She asked me if I was the jester.
So I said to her, no, I'm a messenger of death.
You should have seen the look on her face.
Anyway, she won't be seeing age six.
Wait, we're looking for our guy.
Oh.
Yeah, he loves his job.
Hello, my sister.
Oh, you guys are so right.
Wait, you guys are...
You guys are so right.
Let's not waste time on peasantries.
Gaston Tussaud is still alive.
And it's your job to remedy that.
I suggest you tend to your duties.
I wish...
I had never seen this.
Farewell, sister.
Farewell.
Well, it grew back.
Maybe it's the nostalgia, but I swear he looked better at the original.
I don't know.
But anyways, guys.
This was a lot of fun.
I wish to welcome you to this sanctuary, my newest sister.
Thank you.
We'll talk to more of these guys next time.
I don't know when I'll play next, I'll be honest.
But probably sooner rather than later since...
Hello, my sister.
I'm just talking.
I'm talking.
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you.
Find a job you love and you'll never work a day in your life, right?
I wish to welcome you to this sanctuary, my newest sister.
Please!
I'm trying to...
I'm trying to say goodbye to...
It is an honor to make your acquaintance.
I want to see where this goes.
Cannot be accessed without the proper key.
Wait, I don't have a key?
But I'm a...
I'm a sister.
Okay, hold on.
Same energy as a 40-year-old who went bald early so they buy a hip wig to feel young.
Thanks for the stream we do.
I've been enjoying your oblivion streams.
Thank you!
Me too.
These have been so fun.
I definitely...
I know this time we didn't do the assassination...
...quest.
But we did do this, which I'm happy about.
Yeah, and then we also joined the Thebes Guild.
So...
We did...
We did get some stuff done.
Gosh, this place is so...
Oh my gosh, it's so gothic!
It's just so pretty!
I'm obsessed!
I love this place!
I love it!
I love it so much!
It's so cute!
Like a fairytale!
Truly!
Yeah, where'd you learn your amazing...
Stop!
I almost said it!
What is it?
But yeah!
So...
We'll do...
We'll do some other quests next time...
...before we continue on the main quest.
So great to see you enjoying all the whack this game has to offer.
Thank you for this dream!
Thank you!
Thank you guys!
Sorry that we kind of went on a wild goose chase trying to get that ghost.
But we did do some good exploring too.
Mmm.
And...
This was fun!
Oh, look how cute!
Oh!
This is the door to them!
Wait.
Is it the Mages Guild?
I am a Mages Guild member!
What are you doing?
Lady in the corner?
Go ahead, please.
I understand the Fighters Guild is hiring new members.
Not bad work for some folks.
She's possessed.
Farewell.
Oh my god!
He's an orphan!
When
I'm uncomfortable too!
I just didn't expect it!
Okay, I just...
Ahem!
Stop laughing at the poor 40-year-old orphan!
Oh...
Ah...
It's so funny, I know!
I'm sorry!
It was just so unexpected!
Yeah...
Okay...
Um...
But yeah, we'll do much much more too next time!
And, uh...
Yeah, this was a lot of good fun!
The donation alert is frozen on screen!
Oh, I see it!
Wait, how long has it been like that?
How long has it been frozen?
Uh...
I've never seen it been frozen before!
I refreshed it!
Not that long?
Okay, good.
But, um...
Here, let me save here instead.
Uh...
New save.
Okay.
Cool!
Uh...
Money well spent.
Yeah.
I wish I could put, like a...
Like a...
Hey!
There's a...
What the...
Oh, whoops!
Oh, there's an oblivion portal right here!
But I don't think we'll forget.
Hot dog!
Yeah, next time we'll definitely go and kill the cap...
Capitan!
Can I get this one on top of the other...
I don't know if it would have shown up or not.
A pin marker!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, wait, you can!
I see it!
Beep!
Oh.
Yes.
What the?
No, I didn't set it down here.
Why did it do that?
No, no, I wanted to set it here.
Wait, how do I get rid of this one?
Wait!
Right here.
Move it.
What?
Oh!
Oh, wait!
And now it's here!
Um...
Remove it.
What if I put, like, here?
Oh, so close.
Okay, hold on, here.
Move it.
Oh!
I did it!
Yeah, okay, we...
That's fine.
And I haven't even...
I think I haven't been to, like, most everywhere on the east side.
So...
Black Marsh.
Can we go in there?
Oh, Morrowind.
Oh, probably not, right?
Because there's Skyrim.
Hammerfell.
Valenwood.
Elsewhere.
But yeah, we have a lot left to explore.
I haven't been to this place.
I haven't been...
I only came here for the first time.
I haven't been to...
The...
Oh, the spire!
Is that the place that I can...
Have my home at?
Oh, I want to go to there.
We've done a good bit of exploring on the west side, though.
But I still haven't even been to Anvil.
There's the whole quest about all the people that...
Um...
That were killed in the church.
Gotta go there.
So much to do.
So much to do!
But, um...
Look, there's just a little island here.
We gotta do everything.
And we'll save that...
For another time.
Alrighty!
The house you can buy in Anvil is...
Anvil house is also haunted!
Why didn't you see so sooner?!
Oh...
My...
Gosh!
I need a haunted house?!
What?
Really?
But you still gotta earn the money.
I still...
I have a good amount of money right now.
Thought you wouldn't want to be spoiled.
Oh.
I appreciate that.
What?
Five...
Five thousand?
We need more quests.
Okay.
I'm gonna go now.
Atsumito!
Thank you guys for streaming.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
And I will see you guys next time.
And...
Yay!
Um...
Yeah, I'm gonna go drink some tea.
And...
Eat dinner that's not...
My pastry.
Otsumito!
Itte-rashai!
Thank you so much guys!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Bye bye!
Bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye!
Bye bye bye!